is one of the biggest
stories coming out of the january 6th
riots
uh the loss of life for officer siknik
it's a sad story
and you know my my respect and
condolences to his family but it looks
like now the new york times
has essentially retracted the claims
they made early on
that this officer died due to
essentially blunt force trauma to the
head from a fire extinguisher
now as soon as impeachment is over they
basically come out
and retract it saying actually that
didn't happen
and the official reporting from local
news is that i i don't know which i
don't think it's the us
dc local news i think it was out of
houston but they reported the man died
of an unrelated stroke
this was the big story that violent and
angry trump supporters
brutally and mercilessly beat this cop
and and ultimately killed him
and it was one of the biggest arguments
in the opinion it just was not true
so i can't say i'm surprised but i do
feel a little disappointed in myself
because i i believed it too
we i mean we talked about it several
times on this show and it was just a
whole lot of bs so we have
we'll talk basically about this a little
bit about impeachment the doctoring of
evidence in the impeachment trial which
i believe ultimately led to the whole
thing just
spiraling out of control and collapsing
and uh we got some other news too
biden has gone pretty hard in favor of
gun control which most of us already
knew he was going to do but he's made
the official call
and we do have hr 127 now preparing to
enter committee
which is a pretty drastic gun control
legislation so we'll talk about this
and a bunch of other things we've got
two guests tonight joining us of course
once again is will chamberlain
good to see you so who are you what are
you doing here well i'm the co-publisher
of human events and i'm also senior
counsel at the internet accountability
project which
fights against the abuses of big tech as
well as the article three project
which was dedicated to getting trump's
justices confirmed now i think we're a
little more about opposing
uh biden's judges um but so those are
that's sort of my general work you're
also fighting for social media access as
a civil right
that's correct i mean that's part of my
work at an internet accountability
project
um i mean i've i've long said i think it
should be conceptualized the ability to
use facebook and twitter as a civil
right
well parlor's back so that's that's more
big news yeah i mean a good question
about whether people will come back
um i mean i i well i i made two parlays
is that what it is two parleys
and then the site got hugged to death so
i think they don't have the capacity
they once did
you know back when they were on amazon
they had all this capacity now everybody
rushes back in when the news breaks and
then the site can't handle it
right exactly which is why maybe amazon
shouldn't be able to do that
yeah yeah i agree so we have another
guest but will why don't you introduce
our other guests well well my lovely
fiance is joining us in the podcast
jordan lancaster
um is a reporter at the daily
caller oh and a much more savage than me
on twitter
yeah she's great just give us a you know
brief intro what do you do what do you
do i'm a reporter at the daily caller i
just
pretty much write about everything
breaking news politics
um yeah go on social media tweet
too much that's pretty much it simple
enough yeah and we also got luke
caskey as per usual brutal on twitter by
the way congratulations awesome
also tip tim uh what does the government
do once it disarms its citizenry
uh gulags no whatever they want mm-hmm
welcome back
beautiful and amazing human beings my
name is liquidaski of we are change.org
i am your humble t-shirt vendor
and you could purchase the t-shirts that
i wear on this shirt on the show
another flirty lynch slip on
political charts.com
thebestpoliticos.com thanks thanks so
much for supporting me
what did you just slip
it's 5d you know trickery here you guys
okay he made everybody remember his
phrase
you know they used to do these
advertisements back in the day that were
almost like optical illusions so like a
good example is
there was a picture of a girl on a swing
with three legs and the idea was that
when you're flipping the page of the
magazine
your brain would notice this like oddity
but you wouldn't think twice but then
your brain would remember
it so they would purposefully make these
weird images that people would be like
that's weird what are they doing like i
said three legs that's what luke's doing
grab your attention now you're gonna be
talking about it that's right yeah well
let me grab your attention for a minute
my friends before we get into all that
news talk go to timcast.com and become a
member we've got a ton of exclusive
podcast segments and even a few full
episodes the latest we did we talked
about new foia document proving
the us has alien technology and crazy
meta materials
at least according to a ufo expert so a
lot of fun there and then we got another
segment with matt brainard he's the guy
who ran
the voter integrity project and he
talked to us about his
upcoming report on illegal ballots in
georgia and he made a pretty
bold statement which will you know we'll
leave that segment that that whole news
will be coming out in the next week or
so but for members you can go check it
out
and being a member helps support the
channel in the event that we get banned
because we talk about things that
you know they basically ban people for
it may come soon by being a member
you'll be able to access all of our
content in the event we get wiped out
that's where we will be
but that being said let's jump to the
big news story
it really breaks my heart the national
review reports
the times corrects the record on officer
sicknick's death
sort of the gist of the story the
officer who lost his life
it was an unrelated stroke they say a
few days ago the new york times quietly
quietly updated its report published
over a month earlier
asserting that capitol police officer
brian sicknick had been killed by being
struck with a fire extinguisher during
the january 6 riot
according to the update quote new
information has emerged regarding the
death of the capitol police officer
brian siknik
that questions the initial cause of his
death provided by officials close to the
capitol police
they say as i detailed in a column last
week well the times calls new
information
actually began emerging the same day the
paper filed its january 8 report more
importantly
they initially said law enforcement
sources now they're saying
officials close to the capitol police
what is that
muriel bowser the dc mayor could it be
like a homeless guy who's
next to the police department that's one
thing i always pointed out when they say
close to what does that even mean
well they say official i suppose so at
least it's somebody who's working
they say that report was and still is
entitled capital police officer dies
from injuries in pro-trump rampage
it was not the only such times report
from that day there was another entitled
quote he dreamed of being a police
officer then was killed by a pro-trump
mob
in which the times assert asserted on
wednesday pro-trump supporters attacked
the citadel of democracy
overpowered mr siknik 42 and struck him
in the head with a fire extinguisher
according to two law enforcement
officials with a bloody gash in his head
mr sikdik was rushed to the hospital and
placed on life support he died
on thursday evening but they mentioned
k-h-o-u
uh he reported he had died from a stroke
the story made no mention of the officer
being struck by a
fire extinguisher it did claim however
that the stroke occurred at the capitol
during the riots
and a caption under the officer's
photograph stated that he died of
injuries sustained during the riot at
the capitol isn't amazing how they do
that
check this out we have the actual
article from khou-11
u.s capitol police officer on life
support dies after suffering stroke
following riots union chair said
this is from january 8th how is how is
how how i mean i got to be honest how
did i miss this i mean this story's old
yeah this was one of the big aspects of
the whole impeachment process
the officer who lost his life they did
this big event where they brought him
into the capitol building to lay him to
rest
should we be surprised by this no not at
all i mean the new york times went into
detail they talked about a bloody head
blunt force trauma critical and
conditioned rushed to the hospital
and now we're finding out all of that
what was what was that based on
absolutely nothing where's the
responsibility where's the
accountability
youtube facebook twitter go after these
people for knowingly spreading fake news
if you're going to apply this against
you know the average joe your
independent media apply it to them
whenever there's anonymous sources i
always say there's always reason to be
skeptical
and they use anonymous sources there was
videos showing a fire extinguisher
flying around but
imagine being a reporter at the new york
times right and then just
totally fabricating this story i mean
they're talking about their two sources
who are their sources
you know there should be reviews they
should burn them right like their
sources
lied to them yeah so either they're okay
with that
being lied to about what's effectively
blood libel right you're accusing a
political movement
of murder well obviously i have some
breaking oh god or they did what the
mainstream media usually
usually does and they fabricate and make
up sources that are not there at
all so they do this a lot in the
mainstream media so go ahead i have
breaking news uh
uh it is now confirmed to me from a
source close to nancy pelosi's office
in san francisco that she is in fact a
fascist
who is uh you know selling us out to
massive corporations
and and she is personally
taking bribes from others close to her
office now this source
close to her office is a homeless guy in
the alley you know behind her building
and he seems to be a bit out of it you
know i think he's not getting his proper
medication you see the point i'm trying
to make
yeah if clever were obviously i don't
have any confirmation on nancy pelosi
being corrupt or whatever well actually
i mean
just read the news and you might come to
that conclusion the point i'm making is
this kind of stuff happens all the time
and the new york times lies all the time
and i just
i it's funny that the story came out a
month and a half ago
and the new york times is only just now
updating it and it's not even admitting
fault it's just saying well there's
other
sources saying something different like
you would think that you'd be able to
confirm or deny
the story about him being the victim of
blunt force trauma that's either true or
it's not
and a month after his death we would
know the answer to that question the
crazy thing is
that i got to be honest i think uh i
think a lot of us missed this
i particularly missed it and it's
because we don't read local news
local news is hurting really bad their
their ad rates are drying up and people
are sending their money to the new york
times
so it really is true that we need good
journalists to help us understand what's
going on right now
well just going on in general and
because local news is suffering more and
more people want the national story
more and more people are attracted to
the orange man bad narrative
they ignore what's happening around them
then you have these smaller outlets
who actually reach out to the union find
out what really happened and how is it
that we've now gone into an impeachment
a month later
with this narrative like when when they
when they laid officer sicknick to rest
in the capital
it was well after it was reported he
just died from a stroke
so remember when this first happened and
we were talking about it and somebody in
the chat was like he's actually not dead
yet we're like he has already died
because that was what was first reported
was that he was gone like as soon as
this happened
and that right from the get-go it was
inconsistent what they were talking
about whether he was actually gone or
not and they couldn't make up their
minds
he was on life support yeah i mean this
is supposed to be the paper of record
if they if the journalist isn't willing
to burn their anonymous sources the
journalists should be fired
like i mean you're trying to i don't
know i mean it's just it's
it's it's we shouldn't be surprised that
the new york times's media matters but
like it still
is it still is actually kind of
infuriating that they can't even
maintain the pretense
another thing we have to understand here
this was a very important emotional
talking point we saw a lot of mainstream
media figures and also politicians
talk about the officer that was beat
with a fire extinguisher over its head
until he was
dead beat bloody with a fire
extinguisher over and over psychological
kind of uh you know operation some
people would would say to push
the bigger point that look how horrible
how evil these people are
when in reality they were they were
caught with their pants down they were
lying about this from the very beginning
and
if they're lying about this what else
are they lying about that's the bigger
question americans should be asking
themselves
uh but they're not they shouldn't be
trusted and again i i point to again
the big social tech media companies they
want to combat fight fake news fight it
right now
prove them give us an example of the
mainstream media actually getting a
taste of their own medicine
this is why it's so important that
parlor is coming back
because twitter suppresses news these
big tech giants suppress news i mean
twitter literally shut down the hunter
biden story
and then they they take down parlor with
more fake news so the big claim
when parlor got taken down was basically
that people were organizing on parlor
for the capital riot
and that was a lie so all of this
information coming out is a lie
yeah i mean we're being i mean the the
good example there was facebook was far
more of the center
of that sort of organizing for january
6th um
something like if you actually look at
the criminal indictments like 80 of them
mentioned organizing on facebook there
was plans online
yeah to go after the capital right
there's groups there's individuals
publicly talking about this and then the
the intelligence agencies you know
oh you know we had no idea we had no
clue and then and then when it comes to
the inauguration
huge massive security theater a huge
national guard
because there is a now now there is a
legitimate threat look look you got to
give them some
credit they may have dropped the ball
this time but i mean they've been
particularly diligent in doing their
jobs like when um
when that when the noose was found at
the nascar garage
they were there and they were yes
absolutely
well how many were like over a dozen
yeah so you know when we need the most
they're there i mean who really cared
about the capital
right i mean you know well there's other
reports that i'm seeing that trump
actually requested troops on that day
and he was denied
i still haven't been able to
independently uh verify that's true okay
yeah so
mayor muriel bowser said she didn't want
a massive police presence
when they said they were going to bring
in the national guard she said she
didn't want them to be armed
there were other uh individuals in you
know dc politics saying like oh no you
know
and and it may be that because of black
lives matter and the optics around the
police coming and
you know going after the protesters but
they were guarding the white house
you know pretty diligently i mean there
was fences around the white house weeks
before
uh january 6th so you know something of
course
a lot of people are asking a lot of
questions especially with some of the
people that are arrested
that had ties to the fbi now i don't
want to get all conspiratorial because
because again we have no actual proof or
evidence of this
you have a lot of conjecture you have a
lot of people uh you know connecting the
dots and certain issues but
i think it's fair to say that there
definitely should be a lot more
questions about this event
i i think it's pretty demoralizing man
you know i use the new york times
all the time and i generally give them
the benefit of the doubt
that when they're reporting something it
it's likely to be true not not massively
likely i'm not saying 99
but at least come on 51 there's just
like a banal awfulness
for our institutions right now i mean
you know or rent said something about
the banality of evil i wouldn't call
them evil but they're just awful they're
like not
the banality of awesome there's the
finality of awfulness they're just so
bad
at doing performing their basic function
you know you know
i mean they they've been bad though i
wanna i wanna i wanna sit here and play
this whole like barry weiss angle
you know if those aren't familiar she
worked for the time she wrote this big
letter when she left saying it's like
wokeness and critical theory and
intolerance taking over but the reality
is the new york times has been awful for
a long time
i mean the iraq war you know it's just
like but it's gotten
worse i mean i think the example would
be like they broke the hillary clinton
email story
four years ago yeah you know they they
were they published the snowden articles
when they came out during the obama
administration
there was i think i think there's two
dynamics one is you know trump made them
all
deranged and they became like partisan
as opposed to like just liberal but
trying to be you know trying to be
objective and then i think the second
thing is
you know you see all these woke scandals
of the new york times and i mean they're
so consumed by these internal hr dramas
that they've lost their ability to
perform their function of
being journalists other they're
constantly writing about themselves
yeah that's the crazy thing there's like
another article that came out right now
about the new york times and i can't
remember who but one of these media
reporters ben smith was it ben who was
like the new york times has has become
like
a reality show where they're just
writing articles about their own staff
members now
but people people are clicking it that's
why they're doing it well i remember a
few years ago hearing about their
investigative unit just being totally
gutted
by new acquisitions to the company and
that makes absolutely sense because
if you don't have the budget to
investigate stories or look into stories
or research stories
well you just have to make them up just
like they did in this instance and
and i think it's very fair to say that
this i mean you could say evil
you could say just total ignorance you
could just say total stupidity
whether it is or isn't it's still
absolutely wrong
and bad and it needs to be called out as
much as it can so people realize that
the new york times is not the
newspaper of record it's the newspaper
of whatever special interest or bozo
behind it
uh no no it's the lowest common
denominator of subscribers
so they probably look at their
subscriber base the people who are
paying
you know digitally and they're like
which one's gonna you know attract more
people
or which one will be interesting to most
of the people who watch
or you know who read our stuff and so
you know
i want to make sure that we don't become
like the new york times we are at tim
castaire which is why
we're very seriously looking into
setting up a tv commercial for our
pillow we're gonna we're gonna make sure
that we use our resources
for important things that's right like a
burlap sack full of packing peanuts that
we advertise on prime time cable
just a sort of like a culture jam you
know or whatever but i'm kidding
actually we are we are working towards
hiring reporters and the idea would be
the new york times is going backwards
that's the way i view it
they're supposed to be using you know
all this all this
stuff they report on the funding they
get from subscribers should go towards
journalism that people probably don't
want to hear or might not care about
instead what they're doing is they're
getting rid of the journalism that
people probably don't care about but
still needs to be reported
and replacing it with internal drama and
conflict
what i want to do here is that we have
like we're all sitting here complaining
about the new york times we don't even
do
hardcore investigative journalism so
it's like easy for us to criticize
well we're going in the right direction
in that from a commentary podcast show
we're going to use funding towards
actual journalism
and that's kind of the idea i think
they're doing the opposite but look i'll
give them some respect in that
they do journalism although i'm pretty
concerned about whether i can trust it
at this point and i think you know what
we want to do is particularly different
we'll have a brand that literally
only does journalism so we're like we'll
create a website dedicated specifically
to
just reporting stuff and then we can
keep the commentary off of that
otherwise i don't know man i think it's
demoralizing
yeah it is there is something it's just
like you
you rely on there being some
institutions that
remain nonpartisan i think it's it's
part of a bigger theme think about like
the aclu for example
everybody was great with the aclu when
they were just always fight free speech
cases you knew that it didn't matter if
it was some communist
or some terrible white nationalist
whatever it was if they were having
their free speech rights violated the
aclu would go in and defend them
because they were like the principal
matters more it's about the right now
they don't do that
now they turn down far-right clients yup
because they're uncomfortable with it
um well now they're talking about gender
on twitter right
and i mean i remember i went to an aclu
event you know they were like
celebrating their anniversary they
didn't even have a free speech
like they didn't even talk about their
free speech they're just embarrassed by
it now
well they made a lot of money they made
a lot of money opposing donald trump
and this is why i've never been a big
fan of most non-profits because
they're corporations they care about
their bottom line they have customers
the customers i'll tell you this i think
i think non-profits are actually
substantially more dangerous than
for-profits
in not every single one obviously but
there are good for-profits that do the
right thing that
are maybe sustainable and try to avoid
polluting and there are some good
non-profits that tend to be very small
and they actually want to help people
but here's what i found with most
non-profits they are still just
corporations
the customer is an individual who wants
their hopes and dreams fulfilled or at
least wants to feel
like they're doing something non-profits
make money by convincing you
that you don't have to do anything you
don't got to change your life
you don't have to recycle you don't have
to go and fight for the rights of free
speech just give me 20 bucks and i'll do
it for you and then they don't
they don't but they want to make sure
their customers think
they're getting a product that's the
crazy thing with a for with a poor
profit like if we're selling pillows
like we actually have one's a burlap
sack full of packing peanuts
i actually have to give you a sack full
of packing peanuts
otherwise you're like yo where's my
product not the non-profits not aclu and
especially not the new york times
this is the crazy thing about the news
industry if you call a plumber because
your toilet breaks right
plumber comes in fixes your toilet you
walk over you flush it
it works you say okay my toilet works
here's your money one day you call the
plumber you told us in work he says i
fixed your toilet
take my word for it you flush it nothing
happens you say bro
i'm not paying you how do you know the
new york times or any other news
organization is doing their job
how can you tell the article is the
is exactly what you asked for in terms
of a product legitimate information
you can't you can't check it i mean you
can only guess and i mean you can infer
from the fact that when they actually
report something that's in your area of
expertise it's wrong
right i mean
that keeps happening you just see them
report something i remember i remember
doing this i remember i
went to it was during the flynn case and
i went to a hearing and you know watched
how judge sullivan handled the
defendants and you know came out of that
hearing and
i was there and then i watched all the
news stations reported wrong
like it was just their their description
it was true in so far as they weren't
making
explicit factual errors but their like
entire description of it was super
misleading um that's how it is
during the during the last show we did
when we did super chat someone asked us
this question like how do we trust what
we read
and i went off on a tangent but one of
the things i said if it's an anonymous
source there's a lot of reason to be
skeptical
another thing you really have to ask
yourself when you're reading the news
whether it's even from independent or
mainstream media is who benefits
who benefits from this information and
ask yourself what this is
yeah with this new york times story it's
a you know a lot of independent critical
thinkers use that
term qbono especially when going through
our modern
news lexicon but with that new york
times story
cubono who benefits from that
psychological
emotional damage that was kind of sent
out there to the general public who
benefits from the story being
perpetrated
that these ravaged savages beat someone
over the head and bashed their head in
until their skull exploded
with a fire extinguisher well it's who
benefits off of that cabal
yeah no no no no i i don't know who the
cabal is but time magazine said
that there was a cobalt their words not
mine of wealthy elites
who were conspiring again time magazine
said they not me to fortify the election
well to ensure the proper outcome
of course and so who benefits well the
people who are trying to impeach donald
trump
i would normally just say the democrats
but apparently time magazine says
there's a cabal so yeah i guess it's
canon now
you know you know for a long time people
have referred to the cabal in a sort of
conspiratorial way
and people have been like oh come on
there's no cabal time magazine
an official certified news guard source
you can put in wikipedia now the cabal
and then put a little citation to the
time magazine article it exists i'm half
kidding by the way
but the bigger point is the next story
we have is is coming off of the
impeachment from this weekend
the democrats definitely benefited from
fake news
but they also benefited from the fake
news they created with the evidence that
they doctored
so i don't know if you guys saw this
will jordan the uh
the tweets and the selective video so i
think everybody noticed the videos were
off
they cut what trump said they added
audio like after or in between
but more importantly they actually
showed a tweet that they totally just
made
my favorite my favorite i don't know if
it was a screw-up or not
was when a woman tweeted we're bringing
the calvary
and then was it eric swalwell said she
said she's bringing the cavalry
you guys know what the calvary is it's
like it's like a religious thing
i don't know exactly it's a
representative it's i could be wrong
that is a reference to the hill that
jesus died on it's a very strong
religious reference and i completely
understand what she's saying there
she's like trying to bring religion into
it and make it be like a almost like a
crusade
which also i don't really like but i
kind of understand that better it is an
open-air representation of the
crucifixion of jesus and
they did bring the cross and raised it
on the capitol there you go they were
bringing the calvary
and he said cavalry as if to imply they
were going to be storming the gates on
horseback
they clearly didn't know what they were
talking about well there's more there's
more than that there was a i mean they
changed the date
on a tweet right that might seem small
but that's the year
well so but that wasn't in the actual
trial that was in the new york times
but this is where the media comes in to
lie to everyone once again
check this story out from business
insider they say trump lawyer accuses
house managers of manipulating evidence
by pointing to doctored tweets that
weren't
used in the impeachment trial did you
hear that weren't used in the
impeachment trial
was it in the briefing it was used in
the impeachment trial
what happened was swalwell created he
recreated tweets why well donald trump's
account has been banned
in his recreation an image that was
shown in the new york times had the
wrong date january 3rd
2020 when they presented that same
doctored tweet it was actually two
tweets
in one graphic image they corrected it
to 2021.
to say that they didn't use that simply
because they altered it slightly to a
certain degree
is absolutely insane because what what
trump's lawyers were saying was they
added the verification badge to make it
seem like trump was quoting a public
figure
probably of some prominence telling
people to show up in dc
and to bring the cavalry which like the
funny thing was
when he was saying that the actual image
said calvary
like they didn't know what it was and i
remember when this happened in the trial
i saw an actual lefty journalist say
cavalry or calvary does this guy not
know the difference
and this was like a lefty journalist he
didn't that's that you know what man
maybe the only reason this guy got in is
because fong fong was propping him up
he's still on the house intelligence
committee yes
i mean go back 30 years major any
politician during the cold war
gets caught like oh you slept with a
russian spell right
that's it like that's the end of your
career you are asked to resign by that
your
your party your own party how can we how
can we not be demoralized
when you have a guy who
was aided in his in his campaign for
office by a chinese spy he was
he was sleeping with her right literally
yeah he was sleeping with her yeah those
are the allegations
but he won't answer specifically if he
did or didn't so some people are saying
guilt by association
by by not even responding well i don't
agree with that some people are saying
that but
i'd like proof but let's just we know he
was associated and working with and she
was helping his campaign that's a fact
i wouldn't want to see the proof i mean
oh
i mean the man also parroted a lot of
the communist chinese government
talking points throughout his uh career
fang fang was very instrumental in
raising a lot of funds for his election
and uh the babylon b article said
something like
uh chinese spy sent to internment camp
uh because she was forced to sleep with
uh eric swalwell
chosen tournament camp specifically to
avoid
sleeping with you know again satirical
article
uh but but again major story should
should have been covered more
there should be more attention to this
there should have been at least more
hearings about
what actually was released especially
with him being on the
on the intelligence committee hearings
like what information does china have
from eric here's the point i want to
make here's a guy
who definitely needs to be investigated
because of his association with a
chinese spy
and he's leading impeachment presenting
doctored evidence yeah and look i
i there's almost no point in having the
argument over the veracity or the
severity of the doctrine evidence
you know that the left goes oh it was
just a verification badge it's
meaningless and i'm like i
literally don't care they they created
that image try that in a federal court
yeah you'll get right they'll throw you
out they'll be like what do you how dare
you
sanction you and you will face
discipline at the bar
right if you doctor any sort of evidence
in any way yeah
it's not just doctored he manufactured
the image
it was edited together and they and and
the argument is but it's because trump's
account was deleted
it doesn't matter you can go into the
archives and the woman's tweets still
exist
instead he just manipulated an image
that to me is mind-blowing it shows you
that this was a completely unserious
trial
and then that he just we all knew it was
going to happen
trump is acquitted so so i'm sorry man
it is entirely demoralizing
what do we do you know we i've talked
about culture we need the culture where
i understand
making movies you know ben shapiro is
doing movies we have uh now gina
karana's gonna be doing some
with with the daily wire how do we deal
with this
i mean you know i've been thinking about
this myself because you know i've been
mostly over the last couple years i've
been doing like opinion and commentary
and it's been you know it was aimed kind
of towards influencing republicans
right like not only i mean you know
defending trump from various things that
i think he was unfairly attacked but
also trying to change the republican
perspective
on things like social media big tech
free markets etc
now it's like we again we're confronted
with this banally awful
administration comb with it's you know
conjoined bainly awful institutions like
the new york times
like we need to you need to report on
them they need you know there needs to
be like really good i mean
i think you start with media because
cultures you know politics is downstream
of culture
but we also just need really good
reporting on them um
we need real journalism and uh real
fearless journalism that's willing to
challenge these major institutions and
it seems like
off the top of my head there's only one
name i can think of and it's veritas
they just got banned from twitter i know
right so
they they give they throw every smear in
the book at james o'keefe
and to me it's crazy i certainly think
james is a point of view
i certainly think he's you know
right-leaning or conservative i mean he
speaks it like cpac and stuff like that
right
but it doesn't matter to me i don't i
don't care what your politics are is
what you're telling me true
and important and whenever i look at say
you know veritas is reporting i take
into consideration
all framing and the issue is james
doesn't make opinion commentary like the
new york times does
he just publishes a video and says
here's what they said now maybe
you can accuse them taking these out of
context but why should that phase me
when they do it all day
every day at the very least their
argument is james as bad as they are
or the same as they are there's good
reporting from the times and i try
i try my best to find it and sometimes
they do things like this they do it all
too often
so what well you can't trust a news
outlet that's that afraid of their
readers
i mean the new york times is terrified
of their subscribers
so like why are we trusting anything
that they're saying you know like you're
just
telling these people what they want to
hear because you're so afraid and then
this goes back to the culture war too
like why are we losing the culture war
we're terrified of pissing people off
like we just need to stop being afraid
of pissing everybody off that's
the craziest thing to me like since when
are conservatives worried about
offending hollywood
like you're never going to be in those
movies dude they hate your guts i hate
you
they're gonna hate you no matter what
you say yeah it's just ridiculous that's
a really good point there was something
i saw for uh about fox news
where i think it was was it lachlan
murdoch is that his name yeah
he said something like we're gonna be a
center-right organization because the
right way a news organization serves its
audience is to like present them
information that they they want to hear
whatever or they agree with something
like that
i don't know exactly what he said but
that's exactly it
we've gone from news organizations say
things i don't like but
you know that's the news it used to be
that people trusted the news outlet
and if they heard they didn't like they
didn't blame the news outlet for saying
it
now they do yeah i don't think all hope
is lost i think there's a reason a lot
of these media companies have to turn
off their comments
i think there's a reason why you know
apps like telegram and signal are doing
as well as they are
and uh just even just looking at the
latest comments from the 60 minutes bill
gates interview
there's a lot of interesting comments to
say the least and uh i just looked up
eric swalwell
on twitter and one of the first thing
that comes up is a happy valentine's day
card with him and fang fang on it
so the the culture there the the the
resistance
the people informing themselves and
understanding what's going on i i think
that there's more of that than we
realize on the perception of people
being dumb and angry and stupid
is something that is programmed in the
algorithm to make us believe that's true
but i believe it's more rare
than it is visible on social media no no
i mean you know i'd like to push back
slightly i guess
you know i think about you know i was
the person who said
trump was not going to win back in the
end of november and got like the race
the tweet that was rationed into
oblivion 20 000 20
000 replies all the trump supporters
being like you've you've you've turned
code
and i was right and i mean like they
were all wrong
um and rub it in well right yeah
why are you booing i'm right yeah
exactly
but there's but the point being that
there was this whole there was a very
very strange
political and like dynamic among people
if you were any
involved in conservative politics at all
where you were you were walking on a
tightrope
during in the period after the election
pre-inauguration
where if you even tried to do objective
analysis that was even somewhat
pessimistic
you were getting like hammered for it i
get it you know
a lot of these people who are supporting
trump were desperate and holding on by
threads and so they needed
all the morale they could get yeah and
if a realist steps in it says guys guys
it's threads man they're like no
like you know they can't let go yeah but
it wasn't i kept saying this it wasn't
just
trump trying to win by the numbers it
was trump versus the machine
yeah it was an issue of can trump win
the votes is one thing
can trump beat the machine to the legal
process
with lawyers with public opinion with
the entire establishment against them
that was a bigger question yeah
yeah and in the end the answer was no
however
i do think it's hilarious that even
after they
they beat him in the election they had
to give themselves one final l
like they couldn't just walk away they
were like let's try an impeachment we
know won't work
just to be losers on the way out give
trump the final word
they could have let it go they really
didn't have to well they're not they're
not going to let it go eric swallow is
calling for more investigations and more
hearings he was just
talking about how god is a woman during
this yes
uh during uh you know some of his
testimony that he was on right now
and now nancy pelosi is calling from for
9 11
style commission into the january 6th
insurgency
uh so they're not going to stop talking
about this at all because this is the
only card that they have
a lot of americans are asking them like
hey you promised us a lot of stuff show
us what you got you're in power you have
the house you have the senate you have
the presidency
what can you do for the american people
and they're like
911 commission on donald trump do you
want that
and people are like uh no i don't want
that that doesn't interest me
what can you do for me this is the
american people are asking that and it's
going to become more tumultuous as we
move forward
this is what i love about what the
democrats are doing right now
there's a lot of pundits on the left
that they love projecting
what's going on with democrats onto
republicans and it's funny because the
republicans don't do anything
you know i mean like mitch mcconnell is
he what does he vote not guilty but then
complains trump was guilty it's like
clearly the dude's not doing anything
republican leadership at this point is
an oxymoron but the democrats like to
claim
that republicans don't have any real
policies that's why they're not doing
anything
the democrats have no real policies
that's why all they keep doing is saying
orange man bad well after the orange
man's gone
it's been a month seriously and now they
want to do a new commission
911 style commission to investigate the
capital breach is the next step
oh is it but why impeachment's over
what's the point
yeah the national guard's still in dc
right
i mean i was i left i was there briefly
and i still saw they had all the fences
in the barbed wire
it was they have freezing rain it looked
absolutely miserable
um i think that was the day that the
verdict was announced they're still
there they've still militarized the
capital they're gonna be there until
march
yeah like for what i heard they're gonna
be there longer actually
so i can't remember who exactly tweeted
this joke but they said
something about the national guard is
it's
they're now saying the national guard
will remain in dc until the fall
the fall of what i'd be so pissed if i
was in the national guard and they're
like
you just need to stand out here buy this
barbecue
fence and sleep in the parking garage
and share a bathroom one bathroom with
five thousand other individuals
well so i don't i don't know if exactly
right now but i remember after so
the big controversy was they're making
like 5 000 guardsmen
take breaks or like sleep in a parking
garage with one power outlet and two
toilets
and then there was a big uproar oh how
dare they and then like a week ago they
were like yeah they're still there
like they never got them out the news
cycle just walked away and everyone
forgot about these people
but i've heard from people who you know
who uh
friends of friends of people in the
guard would say that they're they're
extremely demoralized
it's like but but i mean i mean think
about that demoralization has to be
sweeping across this country
just across the board and the the the
issue with that is i'm sure everyone's
familiar with yuri besmanov
he talked about you know that sort of
kgb yeah i think i feel like i've seen
that clip on youtube if you guys
just get sent 50 billion times to us all
day every day but he talks about
demoralization
and what happens when people are
completely demoralized
and they feel like the system doesn't
work anymore there's no justice
nancy pelosi doing this commission is
probably the stupidest and most deranged
thing i've ever heard
to tell the american people at a time
when the news report i think was reuters
1400 checks will hold you over until
july
like in what world will that be enough
for anybody but don't worry don't worry
i know
you're all stressed you can't pay your
rent the moratorium and eviction is
going to be ending soon we're going to
see
millions of evictions but it's okay
nancy pelosi has promised
a 911 style commission on several the
several hundred people who walked
who stormed their way into the capitol
building and uh
while you're sleeping outside you can
rest easy knowing
the full details of what happened on
january 6. it won't change anything in
your life
it won't change who the president is it
won't give you any food
but it's the right ideology hey there
hey hey don't be all negative at least
the pharma industrial complex is going
to have
more profits with their insulin you know
it's not all bad
so why would they have more profits from
their insulin because uh of the
rule that uh biden overturned you know
you know what that actually makes sense
because i was going to say they were
gonna have less profits
because once they evict the people who
are diabetic and they can't have a
refrigerator because
they'll be living outside for their
insulin they'll die so then how do they
make up that
loss of profits from the dead people
jack the price back up yeah
yeah cuomo style it's not all bad the
military industrial complex is also
going to be happy as nato just announced
that they're not going to be leaving
afghanistan anytime soon today
as well thank the lord i was really
worried
you know uh i've long said when people i
see all these activists complaining with
the military industrial complex and
american empire and i'm like
who's gonna bomb the kids if we don't do
it and then when when trump
the abraham accords bringing peace to
the middle east
thank our lucky stars of him i know
that's right
praise be too biden bringing in those
drones and keeping us in afghanistan for
what reason i'm not entirely sure but
apparently they told us it needs to be
done
uh so most of my life we've been in
afghanistan yeah more than half of my
whole life yeah yeah there's fathers and
sons fighting alongside each other
in afghanistan it's the longest war in
american history
and where does the money go where does
the money go where does all the opium
come from the 90
of the world's opium where does it come
from it's a money toilet
yeah and the stories that i've heard
because i've heard from a lot of
you know soldiers that were over there
especially when it comes to
you know we can't even talk about some
of the stuff here that the soldiers
caught and
soldiers were punished in the united
states for exposing
uh the abuse of children in afghanistan
and trying to stop it in afghanistan
uh so it's just an absolutely
horrible thing to be ins and be in i
understand you're hurting
and and if this kind of stuff stresses
you out makes you angry but did you know
that nancy pelosi is putting together a
911 style commission on the people who
stormed the capital feels good
it's the same type we were just talking
about the new york times and their own
naval gazing
being constantly consumed by their own
internal hr drama right okay congress is
now
constantly internally consumed by its
own think about like they spent their
time
trying to expel marjorie taylor green
impeaching the president 911 commissions
like
it's all cell drama it's all reality tv
it's just all internal hr matters
basically within the government as
opposed to doing things
stop being able to perform their
function i almost want to run for office
and when people like what do you stand
for i just be like i'm going to just
build a shed
for this one guy just that that's it i'm
gonna i'm gonna use all of my time
to go like just to local people's houses
and help with their chores
if you elect me i will help you with
your chores because at least then your
tax payer dollars goes towards something
productive
because i can't i can't tell you what
these people are doing right i might not
be there to vote on whatever stupid
garbage bill they're proposing but i
assure you this
if i ever did run i'd literally just
weed your garden
put up some fences for you walk your dog
because then you know your tax dollars
are at least getting you some public
service right
i mean how hard is it like this is the
easiest government program ever
like just give people money like they
did it already they know how to do it
they just write a check they use the
whatever technology they did to put the
money in your pancakes well they even
fumbled that especially with with even
the first
oh yeah there was multiple trials there
was different layers there was
a different time periods when people got
their checks so the government can't
even send you a check correctly
what makes you think they should run
your medical health care
right what makes you think that they
should be in charge of anything
they were life they were giving dead
people money and they were giving money
to non-citizens overseas
like how does it happen that some dude
in a different country wakes up like the
american government gave me money for
some reason we have a social security
number all of us
it's so easy they have the data all they
have to do is literally be like okay
yeah send them a check oh live dead
check
that's it they can't even do they can't
tell you they can't run the post office
and guess what
all of government runs that way spend
spend a few days
spend a few hours even at your local dmv
and imagine these central controllers
wanting to control every aspect of your
life it would scare the bejesus out of
you that's the one thing i don't get
like the people who advocate for
universal healthcare like bernie sanders
does
do they not remember going to the dmv
once yeah
i mean you know that's there's all sorts
of problems that lead to government
incompetence and
and it gets back to the point i was
making earlier there's not a good way to
punish them for lying
i think perhaps you know there's two big
disciplines on our public companies
that and our regulatory system kind of
works for this right the first
discipline is they have to make money
and the second is they have to tell the
truth every three quarters or they risks
i mean they don't always do it but
they're like under a legal obligation
too and they have to file a report
that's examined by
you know stock market investors i want
public lashings
you're a politician you lie you have to
go to the center of the city
and you get lashed by a random citizen
no one wins the lottery the constituent
yeah he's given the cat of nine tails
yes and then you get to
whoop the politicians but in the
buttocks for lying yeah i'll clarify
though because i
do that in somalia by the way i said the
people like bernie sanders because
i actually would like i personally would
like some kind of universal basic health
care
but bernie sanders wants to abolish
private healthcare i think so long as
you have that competition and you have
that choice
i think we'll be okay but i also think
before you can advocate for any before
you can implement any kind of major
social reform
you've got to weed out the corruption
and i think that's the biggest wall
blocking legitimate
social programs and social reform i mean
if you can't even give people two
thousand dollar checks how on earth are
you going to do brain surgery on them
like like yeah not uh government's not
competent enough to do this
and that's the pro the you know the
problem is like when the programs first
start when the government first comes in
there's somebody with a decent idea that
makes sense to a lot of people
but businesses have to fight to survive
they have to make sense
a business has to be able to generate
revenue and profit to hire more
people and grow and if they can they
collapse government when they just can't
do it they just
send more people with guns to collect
more taxes and then pump more money into
something that's not working
yeah so that's always been my thing i
like the idea of social programs the
problem is
well the first question is can they ever
be implemented properly or is the issue
there needs to be an expiration date on
all of them period
i mean you just you have to think about
how you use government and trying to
like
keep whatever it's doing within its core
competency like when i think about for
example
you know what should big tech law look
like you know what i mean i'm advocating
a bigger
governmental role in regulating twitter
and facebook etc well
i'm like okay so we want we want civil
rights style litigation that allows
people to go to court
and pursue their rights like essentially
sue the
the companies because we have courts
they work they they know how to issue
orders and get people to comply with
them
like that's a core competency of
government when you're saying oh
government should literally run the
health care system
you're way outside the government's core
competency
well you know we we talked a bit about
uh
uh giving out checks to people the
government's inability to do things
well we've got another big story that i
think plays into the government's
abilities to do
ability to do things that actually what
you guys are saying makes me a little
bit more confident because we have the
story cbs news reports biden calls on
congress to ban assault weapons
and institute other gun restrictions
suppose the good news there is that
as we just mentioned they can't get
giving up money right
they can't even give people money are
they going to be able to actually
implement
that yeah how are they going to actually
be able to take anybody's guns away or
do anything like that
they seem to have no idea what they're
doing the thing is it won't and it will
create more conflict and it will create
more fights and it will create a really
nasty
situation inside of the united states
and it seems like some people
within our government are hell-bent at
fighting each other and i think this is
exactly what
this particular bigger grab of authority
away from the people is
you're pretty much saying that you're
not you're not saying that guns are bad
you're just saying that
only the special privileged people
should have guns the politicians should
have guns in i don't know why we're not
making this more of a talking point
but gun control specifically united in
the united states is based off
institutional racism and white supremacy
there's a long history of that but hold
on and you would i think
that's that's not even like some haha
got you talking
or not this is actually something the
left does say
all the time because people need to
understand leftists and liberals are not
the same thing
it's the liberal corporate democrat
types establishment types that are like
ban all the guns
leftists like antifa they're like nah we
like our guns
they're pro 2a they're tools of the
revolution they love that stuff yeah
i mean i'm a little i guess i'm a little
more optimistic on the front of what's
going to happen because i think the
courts are going to shut that down
you know much of the early assault
weapons ban
stuff that predates dc versus heller and
the big cases that the supreme court
ruled on which basically
protects the individual right to guns
that are in common use and i think that
there might be no more gun that's more
in common use in the
ar15 it's the most commonly purchased
well so but
first let me just say the the gist of
the story is but i didn't put out this
campaign statement
saying we need to ban assault weapons
universal background checks
what you need to understand about
assault weapons is there have been
there's no definition
yeah assault weapon is meaningless
assault rifle
typically refers to select fire
selective fire rifles so they can do
single burst and full auto those have
been illegal even before they were
invented because of
i guess like was it nfa was that it i
don't know i'm not the smart like the
most gun person ever
i can already see all the chat lighting
up with people saying there's no idea
right correct the point is assault
rifles
are not legal they can do full auto
assault weapon has no unifying
definition
and it makes literally no sense in some
states like there's like a standard
there's like uh uh in some states for
instance the m1 is illegal
and like for what reason is that illegal
and then your standard
like uh scar or whatever is legal
cosmetic differences but i mean
something on assault weapon versus not
totally not related to function
it's it's it's no it's like well that
weapon was once used in war so it's
illegal but the other one that's more
modern more powerful and more efficient
is totally fine
it's meaningless so i i suppose the
the bigger picture is whether or not the
government will be able to
do it and you mentioned you're a bit
more optimistic on the court shutting
this down but my my question is
it's uh the second amendment what is it
what do you know the text of the second
amendment will
uh you know the rights of let's le
i'm trying not off the top of you you
don't need to give it verbatim but yeah
like something because like the a
well-armed or well-regulated militia
being necessary to the health of a free
society the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed what's that last
part
it shall not be infringed before that
the right to keep and bear arms
those two words what were they keep keep
and bear bear means
and that's part of the heller decision
right like the ability to
so i think the later one so why is it
that in dc for instance i can't legally
bear arms
um because courts i mean
the way these amendments are interpreted
they're you know judicial interpretation
judicial gloss
changes things i mean so manipulation
and power i mean people
the politicians in dc are like i'll be
damned if i'm gonna let anyone challenge
me
pre-heller i mean you know before heller
was ruled the ninth circuit
had already decided that the ability to
keep and
you know keep a handgun in your home was
not part of the second amendment
yeah right it took heller to reverse
then be like no there's an individual
right to bear arms in your home
and that's and you know why that's
absolutely insane yeah the initial
language of the second amendment before
it was called the second amendment it
was called like article five or
something i can't remember which article
it
was
there were 17 articles proposed for the
constitution and the first
two had to do with like congress and
apportionment or something like that
but the original text literally said
basically even if somebody doesn't want
to be in a militia they're allowed to
have a gun
and they took that out i guess i was
reading they were worried it would
outlaw conscription
and considering it was you know the
birth of a new nation they're like we
need to be able to force people to fight
wars for us
you know and look i'm not trying to be a
dick like back then we had the war of
1812 you know we had the british
kidnapping people we were weak right
people forget how weak
we were like britain won the war of 1812
and then made a nice piece with us
because they were more worried about
napoleon but you know you know
about i was reading right i was reading
about it how it's one of the few wars
where everyone declared victory
and the only loser was the was the
native americans who were caught in the
crossfire
i mean you know madison sent our troops
up into like canada and then britain
showed up and it's like
oh look you left your capital unoccupied
i guess we'll burn it to the ground
yeah i remember that like and yeah i
mean we were we were losing
badly because they were a massive naval
power we were very very weak
and again i mean again the only reason
they just they just got annoyed by it
they're like okay
napoleon's conquering all of europe
right now that's a little more important
than what those colonies are doing so we
almost we almost took uh
montreal the u.s tried to take montreal
you know and so it's entirely possible
that would have been in america but
so the initial uh uh proposal for the
second amendment
actually was longer and it basically
said in the event even somebody does not
want to join a militia they can still
have that weapon they took it out
and then that leaves us today where you
have these people who are arguing like
it says a well-regulated militia
first of all which definition which
definition of regulated are they saying
regulated in the term
in in the sense of armed and efficient
like well regulated in the sense that
everyone's got a weapon or regulated in
the sense of the government controls
what they do it's a modern
interpretation
off of what they may have also just bad
grammar right like the the first
like people should unknow how to read an
english sentence
the first phrase a preferatory phrase is
like
here is one reason why we're going to
enact this rule
right a well-regulated militia being
necessary to health of a free state
it's like that's one reason we're or the
reason that we're gonna do this
and then we say the rule the right of
the people to keep them bear arms shall
not be infringed
so that's that's the big issue joe biden
says he wants to do this
we've got uh we got the story from
michigan live how riots politics and a
pandemic drove record gun sales in
michigan from february 13th but
this is just one story i just pulled up
i mean we've had record sales record
background checks for the past year
because of the riots the pandemic and
and politics so now
now we're hearing from joe biden he
wants to start banning assault weapons
but by their definition that's like in
some it is the craziest thing you
somewhat one weapon you can buy in say
you know new york
you can't even bring new jersey you
could live in philadelphia
literally on the water you cross over
the other side with a totally legal
weapon not an assault weapon
definition change is outright so the
first thing i have to i suppose they'd
have to do is
define what an assault weapon was and
i'll tell you the scary thing is there
was an attempt several years ago
to define any semi-automatic weapon
as an assault weapon which meant
literally the handgun a cop uses
so i went down to march for our lives
this big the big protests i think in
2017 or 18
and i was asking people and i wasn't
trying to do this gotcha stuff that you
often see on youtube where they're like
you're so dumb explain it you know like
jimmy kimmel does or whatever i saw
people holding signs saying ban assault
rifles
and so i would ask them like are you
aware that they're already banned and
then they would go oh and they would
like pull their sign down and fold it up
and then hide it like i guess you didn't
realize i wasn't trying to get you
and then i would ask some people very
simply i had the bill pulled up that was
proposed
that would make like a glock 17 illegal
as an assault weapon
it would literally define the handgun as
an assault but one of the most common
weapons in the country
and so i would ask people do you think
assault weapons should be banned yes
do you think that includes say
semi-automatic handguns and they'll go
no of course not
what about like you know a glock 17 or
something like a cop would use or a
glock 19.
and they would be like no no no no
that's that we just mean high-powered
rifles where you can get off like 30
rounds in a few minutes
and then i would show them the bill you
know from like gov track and i'd be like
here's the current bill do you agree
with what the democrats are proposing
and they'll go oh no no i absolutely do
not agree with that
and i'll be like i mean maybe it's
important that you know all these
millions of people coming out here
know that i mean you you'd come out here
and a lot of people were shocked
they didn't realize just how serious it
was that there have been proposals even
to get rid of
semi-automatic you see i don't know if
you guys remember that uh
what was it cnn or whatever where they
they said fully semi-automatic what
[Laughter]
right yeah like they don't even know
what they're talking about
and so there's a lot of people who think
semi-automatic means you hold the
trigger down
full full auto it's not it's it's it's
remarkable how
uh so i recently i i guess you're not
supposed to say what kind of weapons you
have
but look it's probably fine if i
mentioned this one i just got right you
think it's i don't know
what the the big one no no no no no
well no the hunting one okay so i got a
i got a bolt action
450 bushmaster ruger and uh when i was
buying it
they were just basically saying to me
like you should have no problems with
this bolt action it's great
it's excellent for hunting you know it
was designed for for you know for for
deer and stuff like that
and i was like oh that's perfect in the
event we do want to go hunting or
something like that and we want to go
out with somebody
and then i asked them i was like why is
it that they regulate the the
you know the ar-15s but this thing is
like just not even on the books and they
were you know well because they don't do
what they're talking about and i had
several people tell me that less moving
parts
on the the the bolt action uh the bolt
action 450 these are these are you know
decently large rounds
they're more accurate at longer
distances they're potentially more
dangerous from somebody who wants to
cause harm
but because these politicians have no
idea what they're talking about they
think the scary black
looking rifle is a military weapon it's
got to be banned meanwhile this
hunting rifle which is actually more
deadly and more accurate they're like oh
that's fine
that's that's what well you know what i
think the better way to put it is
i can talk all about this stuff as i'm
discovering it and exploring it as i go
to the gun shop and i'm buying these
things and a lot of the people who own
guns are sitting there laughing banging
like ah he's
they're laughing like ah young tim
finally learning what it's like
but here's the funny thing about it it's
also a wake-up call to
it's it's kind of like the gel man
amnesia effect for those that aren't
familiar
the idea of the galman amnesia effect is
when you read a news article about
something you're familiar with
so let's say you're a a gun owner and
you read a story saying assault weapons
will be banned
and then they make reference to things
that don't exist they they
get assault weapon wrong and they define
words you laugh like these journalists
have no idea they say fully
semi-automatic they're so dumb
you turn the page and then it's like
conflict in syria 50 dead and you go wow
i didn't know that
the idea is you all of a sudden forgot
how incompetent these journalists were
i suppose there's another effect i would
like in this too is
people believe in government until they
realize there's an area of government
they're familiar with
and how awful it's being controlled and
regulated so as soon as you start
getting into like buying guns and going
to class which a lot of people are doing
all of a sudden you go if they're doing
this really bad
what other regulations do we have that
are just as bad
if they don't know what an assault
weapon is and can't define it
how are they handling medicine so this
is super funny to me because the
lady who sold me my personal weapon of
choice
um in a different state was like well
the state that you live in does not like
this gun because it looks scary
and that kind of struck me as strange
because i was like the people who are
actually regulating the things that we
can and can't buy this literal right
that we have that's in the constitution
they have no idea what they're talking
about they know nothing about what
they're saying
and they think that they have a right to
like tell us what we can and can't do
it's in the constitution i'm sorry you
may not like it well
another thing to really consider here is
is this this is a very unpopular move by
biden
people have been buying guns in record
numbers even in big cities
even a lot of people on the left yeah a
lot of people on the left have been
buying firearms and i i truly believe
this is
done in an effort to push for more chaos
order out of chaos is usually the big
kind of agenda that you see from a lot
of these politicians that try to stir up
a whole bunch of problems and then come
in with the larger solution
at all costs we need to prevent violence
from happening
and uh the people in brazil are having
the opposite problem as i'm learning
right now
i'm reading an article that's talking
about how bolsonaro
in brazil is trying to make it easier
for
citizens to get guns more easily
and uh the guardian has a propaganda
article about this and it's titled anger
as bolster narrow moves to make guns
easier to access
a threat to democracy people need to
understand
when you're armed with a firearm this is
what politicians are protected by so if
the politicians could have protections
why can't the average citizen
be able to protect themselves and their
properties when it comes to criminals
like in mexico or let's say chicago
places where guns are illegal
criminals still magically get guns and
firearms we got we got to talk about
this story
all right we got the story from reason
this gun shop says
it won't do business with biden voters
yeah in missouri
no in michigan oh tech companies should
have the same freedom to choose their
customers so this is a michigan-based
ammunition shop
is refusing to sell to any customer who
voted for president joe biden in the
2020 election quote
we've had a few potential customers call
this morning ask why they have to check
a box
stating they did not vote for joe biden
in order to purchase our ammunition
phoenix ammunition tweeted yesterday
morning the answer joe biden ran on a
campaign built on the most radical gun
control platform
a major party candidate has ever had
including banning the online sale of
ammunition
this says phoenix is essentially a plan
to bankrupt our company
that's true i couldn't believe it when i
read that joe biden said we will ban the
online sale of ammo
why what what's seriously the problem
there
that that that's great their whole plan
is like we're to throw as much sand
in the gears of gun ownership as we can
for what reason but but also you have to
look at
strategically here this is against the
best interest of the united states
national security one of the things that
makes america strong
is its armed citizenry when you take
away the arms geopolitically we
we become weaker on the world stage well
i mean like
what since when has like what's good for
the american people stopped democrat
well politically i would say political
ideology
and i want to be fair too republican
gets excluded from that because
republicans mostly do nothing
yeah right what did trump do for the
second amendment i mean nothing
well no he did worse he did bad for yeah
banning bumps i mean
really the big proposition you know the
value proposition of republican
governance is that they won't do more
bad things
not that they'll do good things to
improve your life right they'll just
they'll just avoid doing the bad thing
but when it comes to trouble
and the bump stock ban he went further
than democrats would have even wished
democrats usually uh grandfather in
people and their firearms and their
accessories donald trump
made americans felons overnight with the
signing of a pen something that of
course democrats weren't able to do
trump did
i want to read more of this so uh
there's another quote they say
uh in a series of follow-up tweets the
company stressed that it was perfectly
willing to give up potential sales to
people who voted for biden
where dead serious phoenix ammunition
tweeted we don't want your money
and you shouldn't want us to have it
because we're going to use it to make
more ammo
sell it to the citizenry and do
everything in our power to prevent joe
biden's administration from usurping the
rights of americans
we have no problem talking to biden
voters and educating them on what they
did
but they have to be willing to
acknowledge their ignorance at the very
least
we are not going to sit here and debate
with you we are a 2a company
and these are our first principles
phoenix ammunition's announcement has
provoked a wave of positive attention
from the right
many are applauding the company for
sticking up for its beliefs and
declining to do business
with people it sees as a threat to its
business model i love this
quote private company tweeted perennial
maga gadfly jack pasobic
the implication being that because
phoenix is private it can do it at once
he's right of course phoenix is
perfectly within its rights to reject
customers who voted for biden
or for any other reason related to a
person's politics not in dc by the way
in dc politics political idea ideology
is a human right
and then they go on to say i love this
and so is twitter and youtube and
facebook and reddit and so on
yet when it comes to these private
companies rejecting customers based on
their ideological beliefs and political
statements
besovic and many many others on the
right have been whining
and objecting nonstop they insist it
violates their rights somehow
they champion proposals to force these
private actors to carry speech they
disagree with
and cater to customer bases they find
objectionable they support federal
action to punish private businesses
for not being politically neutral so
which is it who
who wrote this and why are they simple
is it robbie no it's elizabeth nolan
brown it's reason oh come on
reason yeah libertarians yeah so they're
right they don't get that it's
like jack's joking right right if you
actually go to jack and you say here's
the deal
we can regulate private companies and
prevent them from discriminating against
you politically on facebook and twitter
but here's what you have to give up
you're the random gun shop in michigan
also has to serve biden voters
he'd be like uh yeah i'll take the
regulations right right right
you know he's clearly joking saying
private company is poking fun at all of
the people
this is really funny where libertarians
break from a lot of conservatives and
you know one
of these issues and they're more aligned
with liberals on this one that
so well actually let me just say somehow
that happened when did when did pro
corporate
libertarians you know i should say pro
corporate but pro
private right for companies break from
conservatives on the issue and join
the liberals well it's more like the
liberals were always for the regulations
you know
the liberals realized both the liberals
and conservatives actually hold
political power at times libertarians
don't
so that that's kind of where you start
um and so
liberals realize that it assisted them
in their attempts to hold and wield
political power
if they were going to indulge the right
of corporations to censor their
ideological adversaries
and so liberals who under in any other
context would never talk about how
private companies can do whatever they
want
uh are suddenly saying oh actually
facebook and twitter are uniquely in the
position where they should be given full
autonomy um whereas conservatives are
you know like me are also you know
generally being like no generally the
free market's a good idea but i'm sorry
i don't like being discriminated against
right that's the difference between
absolute like bottom of the spectrum
libertarianism
of you know free for all essentially and
well we need some government we need
some regulations
well i'd love to hear a libertarian
explain why if you know given this
position that they have of like oh
you should never interfere with the
private companies right to do what they
want um how
they whether or not they could oppose
and these 1964 civil rights act and
support the repeal
of that law they do support the appeal
of it some do but like
many don't or and many certainly aren't
willing to talk about it i mean i
actually did it like joe jorgensen
yeah i did debate with robbie suavey on
this and he just disassembled
horribly on it i love robbie but like he
he had a rough time when you know
he was talking about the right of
facebook and twitter sensor people i'm
like okay it's like
do you you know oppose the 1964 civil
rights act he's like well yeah i do i'm
like okay so you're for
you know hotels and restaurants
discriminating being able to
discriminate against black people it's
like well you know and
it's just it's the craziest thing
because i've never moved on this
position
like i've always been in this like this
this was the center left
pro-regulation when corporations were
interfering with the rights of
individuals becoming too powerful
that's when the people band together and
say you have too much power and it's
causing us harm
so you know interestingly like this is
where you know the libertarians were
educated like i feel like i was educated
in this way that
was saying like actually you know you
know really the problem was government
and you know all those civil rights they
would have been protected and
and the issue was government
intervention and goldwater was right the
civil rights act went too far and then
you know i look back at that you know 10
or 12 years ago will i'm like that was
dumb why did i believe that that that
was clearly
like historically wrong and just very
very ideological
well you know the story behind how like
uh i
this is one of the stories of how we saw
the end of segregation was i think it
was lyndon johnson
he had some black men who worked for him
and he asked them i told you the story
you told me the story there yeah
oh what did you write this up for human
events yeah i wrote this up tell the
story mix
it's a brilliant story so i mean this is
in uh robert carro's biography
right but so lyndon johnson had these
uh you know had black employees and a
couple of them he had drive his car
all the way back to texas from dc every
year and
um there usually wasn't a big deal but
one year he wanted them to take his
their his dog back with him and they
were like please don't make us do that
and lynda's like why like what's the big
deal you have a dog in the car who cares
and
he's like do you understand what it's
like to drive through the jim crow south
with a car like we have to drive you
know 40 miles
off the main drag just to find a place a
hotel or a restaurant
like and then and many times we just
have to sleep in the car
uh and we have to do that now with a dog
too are you kidding
and it was sort of that moment that was
just crystallized like wait we don't
have to let that happen
like we could you know whatever's going
on in the south we don't have to
tolerate
people not being able to go to a motel
or a restaurant
on the road and having to go we just
don't have to tolerate that we can say
that that's illegal now
um and to me that's just really powerful
of
you know you can come up with all these
you know rationalizations and
hypotheticals about what would have
happened in the absence of some
early horrible government intervention
and every bad thing is the fruit of that
early government intervention like
libertarians to
try to argue you know i hear a lot from
libertarians that oh eventually these
businesses would have failed and their
competition would have succeeded
i think the key word is eventually like
how long would that take
and i think maybe is the right word but
here's another here's another point like
put yourself in the position of a
restauranteur
or a motel owner in the jim crow south
just on some random
you know stretch of highway are you
making money hand over fist
in the 1960s no you're not
right you're a restaurateur in the jim
crow south in the 1960s
so in you know in the abstract like if
some
black person came in even even if you
had like maybe where someone inclined to
racism you might say like
well we need the money so we're
perfectly happy to serve you but
the problem was there was this private
like the problem was like this
widespread racist disgust
among the customer base and so you know
if there were
so many white customers who were racist
and would not stay
in a motel that and that was integrated
and so
that private consumer demand for
discrimination
was sustaining the racism and there's no
there was no
you know that would have continued the
libertarians are wrong that would have
just continued on
right um and i think i mean think about
all how the private this private
discrimination is being used now i mean
it's
again not the same quality much worse to
be racist
but we see how progressives act today
how they try and use collective pressure
to exclude conservatives from public
life like
well how does the market solve that a
really good example that there is a
problem of ideology
is gina carano posts a tweet disney
fires her lucasfilm fires her
so when an individual employee her as
the star of the show the mandalorian
says something political the company
says oh we can't allow that that's
offensive you're fired
you then know the story of this uh this
uh restaurant
where one employee wanted to wear a
black lives matter mask and the business
said basically the same thing disney did
you can't have that you can't wear it
sorry so the activists got the business
shut down it doesn't matter if you're
the employer or the employee when you
oppose the cult they come after you
that's what i think is funny about this
gun shop story is that you have one gun
shop who's saying we don't want to do
business with biden voters well how many
businesses have
turned around and said we don't want to
do any business with trump supporters
like
exactly maybe not huge corporations
aren't publicly saying that but
i've seen small businesses on instagram
and facebook posting and saying if
you're a trump supporter we don't want
your money
that's the funny there was that remember
that video where the vape shop guy is
screaming at the top of his lungs
because guys wearing a maga hat
like dude it's one thing when phoenix
ammunition is like
you know hello there good sir but a
biden voter i'm sorry take your business
elsewhere it's another thing when a guy
walks with a maga hat
and the vape store guy goes because he's
screaming as loud as he can it's
so mundane discriminate that's where
discrimination conservatives against
conservatives is so mundane that we
don't even talk about it it's not even
news
right it's news when a conservative
business discriminates against liberals
not the reverse
yeah right i mean it was meme worthy
when the guy was screaming
the guy's like i'm wearing a hat bro
what's wrong with you so does this prove
that the government intervention didn't
work
in into and now in our current modern
day circumstances well no i mean there's
no government
prohibition on political discrimination
right but there is a government
prohibition on racial discrimination and
i think honestly when you're looking for
things like government policies that
work that ultimately achieve their
objective
i think the civil rights act of 1964 you
can fairly say achieved its objective i
think it accelerated
um you know it massively accelerated
integration in the jim crow south and
um here's radically transformational do
you think we're regressing especially
with some i i forgot what this picture
was from but there was a mandatory
meeting
uh people of color had to go in one
place people said white people had to go
yeah it was in seattle
do you think we're regressing back into
that sure i think we are um but that i
think that particular type of
discrimination is definitely
vulnerable to lawsuits um i think and
chris ruffo i don't know if you've had
them on yet
oh yeah okay so chris ruffo's awesome
and i think he's
whenever the left tries to go so far and
actually do does
wants to do racial discrimination on its
own it's vulnerable to having the civil
rights act brought in
to wield against it the political
discrimination problem on the other hand
like we don't currently have the law we
kind of need
except in maybe a few jurisdictions i
think california and dc have some
political discrimination protections
but in general i think like that's
that's got to be a project of the right
to say
look the free market is not going to
save us it and and i think
it's it's it's yeah there's a lot of
free markets republicans are not going
to do that
mitch mcconnell you know you know his
professional you know i'll give him a
catch phrase slow down there
democrats that's it that's what he does
i mean he he might not do it but he's
old
and he may not be in office too much
longer and i think about
i'm more optimistic on this front
because you know two years ago i was
saying platform access is a civil right
and people were calling me crazy
like leftist they're calling me a like
michael mallis did that you know i
actually thought
he you know he didn't call me akami but
he's like you're coming from leftists
background and you know i basically you
know i did redid his podcast and
it's just everybody's sort of come
around to where i was two years ago in
this radical position
i had a conversation with a libertarian
in milwaukee at the mythicist event
and i wasn't i wasn't there to beat them
i ended up doing and i ended up on a
panel because someone wasn't able to
make it but i was i was in the green
room
and there was a bunch of sitting around
talking to this libertarian and i said
we need regulation of big tech companies
in some capacity be it
the the insuring of the freedom freedom
of speech because they've taken the
commons
or some kind of regulation that says we
need to like reform of section 230
and he said i don't i don't believe you
have a right to tell a private
institution what they're allowed to do
and i was like dude i've heard the
argument i don't care
if you want to sit back while your ideas
are completely erased from the public
space
by all means do it because my idea is
i'm not a libertarian i'm actually in
favor of regulation
and that's what i'm arguing for so in
five years when you d when your
political ideology is gone it doesn't
exist
who's going to who's going to argue for
you but also i think we need to make a
distinction between private business and
also monopolies that control information
highways
and also monopolies specifically that
are connected to governments in many
different ways so i think there's a
difference between the the
you know the the cake owner versus
twitter facebook
oh yeah you know i randomly get
questions from people who say things
like well if you
if you think you should regulate twitter
why well how could you possibly oppose
regulating the cake owner i don't
i'm like i well from my my answer to
that is i mean i think
that's a perfectly consistent position
to think you should regulate both yeah
right but i think
that it's okay for society to impose
larger burdens
on billion dollar companies than on
small entrepreneurs
that's right like it already does that
we do that in insurance we do that in
common carrier
i mean there's so many different areas
of law that treat
think obamacare even right small
businesses are treated very differently
than larger businesses so that's one of
my first arguments in that
when a when a corporation grows large
enough to
cause damage to the public we then come
in with regulations
one bakery saying i refuse one thing or
another
is not causing massive damage to the
entirety of
the the area however in the in the in my
actual
position is look when it comes to the
bakery what people need to understand
and most people who watch us probably do
they didn't deny service they denied a
custom message
so the baker basically said you could
have any cake that we
or or we can custom make one for you but
we won't write that
and so they sued over it my position is
i know a lot of people don't like taxes
libertarians don't like taxes
taxation is theft for the time being if
i'm paying taxes to sustain
a common area common infrastructure
pipes sidewalks police fire department
ems all of that stuff and you are using
that infrastructure to
support your business that means we are
all contributing to the betterment of
your business i believe
you haven't you have an obligation to
reasonably service
the public if someone comes in and is
committing crimes screaming disruptive
disorderly
threatening all that stuff by all means
we kick them out because that's you know
an affront to everyone in the public
but if we're all contributing to the
space to work and live together
and i come into your shop i understand
the argument about the free speech and
being forced to write something and
that's a good argument so
i'm kind of on the fence on that one but
overall i think
businesses should provide a a you know
equal accommodation
to members of the public and i i think
that's a cl much closer question
than the question of whether or not it's
just to regulate twitter which i think
is
very one-sided in favor of yes it's
perfectly just to regulate them
i mean they're a multi-billion dollar
company that's monopolized a large
section
of this public square and that people's
first and
right now people's first amendment
rights aren't really that meaningful i
mean think about how much
just you know we've donald trump has
been banned from twitter for six weeks
think about how much the volume's been
turned down on him
from losing his twitter account yeah
well it's not just twitter i mean
you can go walk down the street and have
a different baker bake a cake
but you know what you could go to parlor
not anymore i mean i guess now they came
back but
before you go to parlor and then parlor
got shut down and yeah there's a big
difference between private space and and
government monopolies
that's the thing that we need to really
really uh you know beat into people's
heads the the one of the ways i put it
when it comes to social media and why
regulation is important is you so like
you said you can go to one
baker and he says no so you walk down
the street to another baker he says yes
there's market competition you can
probably find something
even if parlor exists twitter
is basically the la coliseum football
stadium
the president is in the middle of the
field yelling all of his ideas to the
people
and they kick you out and you can walk a
few miles away
to a small soccer field at a high school
where the local principal is giving his
ideas
so do you have meaningful access to the
president and politicians who are
verified using this platform
in mass that twitter actually gives the
like will put the position they have as
a politician in their
under their name they recognize
politicians aren't
using a bunch of these other platforms
so the problem i see is
sure there may be some competition there
may be parlor there may be mines
trump doesn't use any of them so are you
going to be able to hear the president
speak
imagine if when television was invented
a radio
when if the president was gonna was
going to give an address they showed up
to your house and said you can't have
the radio on here the president they
came in and turned it off on you
i mean people don't have access to cbs
or nbc anymore you can't yeah
we where they put a giant metal dome
over your house you can't get any radio
waves we've banned you from collecting
this information
it's crazy to me that they restrict you
from even hearing
maybe the answer is to ban people from
posting but not from following
you know what i mean well i mean you can
make the argument they already do that
because you can always like
lurk on even if you've been banned from
twitter you can lurk and read
why why ban you from subscribing to the
president's posts because you said
something
instead of banning your right to say
something well what they did to trump is
like
they kicked him out of the coliseum and
then burned the soccer field down
he's been from spotify yeah like what is
he gonna do like listen to too much
music like
he's been from pinterest when he's gonna
plan a wedding right like
it doesn't make any sense i love when
like twitch banned him
like oh no the president's gonna play
minecraft and and espouses ideology to
kids who are building
twitch were smart they would have just
allowed the president on and like
massively built up their platform
donald trump playing minecraft what is
this green guy doing
why is he constantly trying to get me i
don't understand
that'd have been hilarious yeah uh you
know i can uh
i pulled up a meme but i i don't know i
guess there's not really there's no real
reason to show it now i guess we should
just jump
well i want to show it anyway let's show
them any memes what is this so when we
were talking about
libertarians and regulation it's the uh
libertarian ideas and libertarian
candidates meme you guys know this one
oh yeah there's you ever seen it no it's
this very beautiful and gorgeous fox and
it has libertarian ideas
and then the next one is this scraggly
looking all messed up muppet
says libertarian candidates yeah
i i i think it's funny but the reason i
want to pull it up is because we're
actually talking about bad libertarian
ideals
yeah no i'm i'm i'm someone who used to
be on the bleeding edge of
libertarianism i worked for the
seasteading institute i don't know if
you're familiar with that
but we were the idea was to build
private islands that were private
areas of sovereignty there's some funny
videos of libertarian will though
yeah they're out there you can finally
pull some of them up you can find them
and then correct me if i'm wrong the
idea is to live outside of
any government jurisdiction and you make
your own government at sea
right like in that the idea that just
having seasteading having an environment
where they can compete and people can
move around between sovereignties very
easily without the law
you know would it would also just put
competitive pressure on existing
sovereigns to behave better right that
was the idea
uh it doesn't work but turns out i don't
i don't think the precept works because
there's no meaningful way to evade the
sovereignty of major nations
right like you can't just you can't just
have a drug den offshore in the united
states
and expect the fact that you just have
to have the cia run it yes
stiltsville you know stiltsville in
florida no i don't know
so uh off the off the coast of florida
it's actually not very deep
it's like you can walk very very far out
and so
or you know sort of walk you actually
when you go out
south of uh south east of miami
you have to be very careful when you're
boating because you could you could
crash into rocks like it's the
waters not very you know deep but uh
stiltsville was where they built a bunch
of buildings on stilts
and were gambling and partying and
drinking off
shore from miami because you know there
you go you want to you know gamble
found a place to do it just in the water
yeah i mean there's i thought this was
america
ultimately with the tacit permission of
the federal government this is
this is funny when when people say this
is america they think it's the land of
the free
we were substantially less free like
what a hundred years ago in a lot of
ways
uh what uh you probably know is better
than better than i do will but uh i
believe our modern interpretation of
free speech is fairly recent like 1960.
yeah i mean it's been it's definitely
been dramatically expanded although i
mean there was
there was definitely there was still a
lot of protection for it even in
i mean there was there were some
prosecutions that were really aggressive
like the anarchists i think and
abraham lincoln as well when he went
after people journalists
well i mean you know during the civil
war we did a whole a lot of things that
weren't exactly pro liberty
uh yeah you know that's that's crazy the
constitution became meaningless
people died for their speech like during
the civil war i mean think about the
logistics of it like
you don't really think about it but the
entire north and the entire south were
fighting and the opposing capitals were
two hours away by car
right 100 miles away and and so as a
result like washington
dc was very vulnerable right like it's
surrounded by
slave state virginia and then slave
friendly maryland
right like you know there were i think
they were maryland's a slave state so
surrounded by slave states
um they were worried about their
railroad connection yeah being severed
uh so you know abraham lincoln was like
nah now that kind of yeah so there was
there was like i mean they're like we're
in a war you're rising up against us
we're not going to commit suicide
yeah so you can i mean you can say a lot
of things i mean
you know but lincoln the tyrant i know
there's there's some weird like von
mises institute stuff
from like that's like lincoln was
actually a tyrant during the war i'm
like he was he was in a civil war that
was not obvious he was going to win
especially at the outset
um they kept losing battles they had a
giant mob of tens of thousands of rebel
soldiers as far north as
you know as for you know they got to
bull run which is gettysburg
gettysburg pennsylvania yeah that's like
super far north
that's crazy and i mean they ultimately
lost and they probably i mean as
but you know there were times in you
know their strategy you know stonewall
jackson they wanted to attack
philadelphia
they wanted to attack yeah this is the
crazy thing too about you know when you
when you look at what lincoln did
i'm pretty sure we're all kind of
grateful he did it but it's kind of
scary at the same
at the same time yeah suspension of what
habeas corpus right
arresting journalists i mean it was it
was the 1860s it was a war
the federal government was so much
weaker as a general matter i mean
you know one of this is also one of the
things i don't like when people talk
about like oh we should have a
revolution of civil war like one civil
war killed five percent of the american
population is one of the worst things
that ever happened to our country one of
the bloodiest wars in history
like just in terms of the number of
people who died um and second
uh our federal government is so much
stronger now than it was then
i mean the southern army's literally
they just they marched sorry southern
forces just marched into federal armies
and took the guns and yeah that would
never happen now
there's no way like any state militia
would be able to summon the
well but but the the issue is any modern
civil war would be an actual civil war
the united states was was particularly
unique in its in its you know earlier
stages
in that it was a bunch of states that
viewed themselves as
you know fairly equal to the federal
government and you know in some to some
degree or at least
protecting of their own rights when you
look at some other countries that went
through civil war
notably like spain it was just different
areas adopting the ideology and taking
aside
so what we would actually see in the
event the us did go to civil war is like
when john podesta had that war game
where he said if trump wins the west
coast secedes
it's not going to be like a federal
armory and then
the national guard of washington goes in
it's going to be the federal base is
in washington and it's hard i don't
think i mean but my point is i guess i
don't think it'll be that easy for
whatever side wants to repel
i just don't i think the federal the
federal government of the united states
is still
even with all its confusion and
incompetence is the most powerful
institution but it's it's not going to
be
one faction against the federal
government it's going to be the federal
government split in half
yes see i i guess my point is i don't
think that can really happen
uh it's like that there's federal
control is consolidated so it's
literally like what side does the army
take
well there's states like texas that have
a lot of national guard troops located
inside of them that are openly talking
about secession sure but i think i mean
that's that that ultimately would end up
being like guerrilla warfare like you
could see like guerrilla revolutionary
times
insurgency insurgency but i don't think
you could see
i don't think you could see anything
resembling where you had like
two you know the civil war was two
armies right walk you know of tens of
thousands of people showing up
public and shooting at each other but
but look so so but
stop like don't think about it in terms
of what america did in their civil wars
that was very unique in terms of global
civil war
back then it was a bunch of different
state with states with state identities
sure today we're the united states
like uh it's it's that that line from
national treasure
one of the most brilliant quotes a
famous famous man what
what's the character's name tom gates or
whatever from i don't know nicholas
cage's character yeah
he said before the civil war people
would say the united states
uh are after the civil war they would
say the united states
is it stopped being plural it the united
states became the name of a single
nation
as opposed to a reference to different
states yeah i don't know if that's
actually true it's just from a movie
but the general idea i think it to make
you know
to fit into this analogy is right now we
are
one country the state's rights are
relatively meaningless compared to what
the united states is
people don't vote vote in local
elections i mean they do but most people
don't even know who their congress
person is or who their senator is
or who their state senator is or who
their mayor even is
isn't that crazy a lot of people i
wouldn't say everybody but a lot of
people probably have no idea who their
mayor is or who their sheriff is
yeah so but i'll tell you this they've
they probably know who like
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi or at
least heard of them federal level
politicians
have basically replaced local
politicians because we're becoming one
country
so you look at you the concern i suppose
and and it's
reflected in the decisions being made in
dc
why are they vetting the national guard
because they're scared
that there are certain groups that are
aligned with the
trumpism faction they actually do fear
that
federal military forces might actually
split
or there could be like the the way it
happens isn't like one day
a bunch of people in the army or marines
or whatever say we hereby declare
ourselves for trump nation
what happens is confidence breaks people
don't have faith in the system from mass
demoralization
they reject orders or are ordered so
they're ordered to do something they
don't want to do
maybe there's a bunch of uh maybe it's a
town in middle america
and they're refusing this draconian
lockdown saying we refuse
our people are suffering and then
certain military are order do something
they don't want to do
and that caused a frac causes a fracture
the civil war took place over a decently
long period of time people people look
at history and they viewed a condensed
matter like all of a sudden it just
happened
i think what was it like 20 years of
strife conflict back and forth in
government
until finally one congress person gained
the other guy
and then ultimately it led to i think
seven states seceded
and still that we didn't have a civil
war it was only after
this session already happened then fort
sumter when the union refused to bring
their troops out
after that happened more states then
broke away and it caused
a rapid collapse so in the event
something does happen
i think people need to for one don't
think it needs to be armies
like it doesn't it could be fifth
generational warfare we could literally
just be in the modern equivalent
we use the internet we use propaganda
it's information war or
it could just be radically different
than anything you've ever experienced
yeah i i won't rule that out um
i i got to tell you man look they're
telling us right now
that they're going to give us a 1400
check well i shouldn't say us because
it's not coming to me that's for sure
they're going to give the average
working-class person 1400 bucks
i threw up my mouth a little bit when i
heard that because i'm like dude i
complained about the mass printing of
money but come on
the american people have been have been
taken taken to boot up the butt from
from these lockdowns
the very least we can do is borrow from
ourselves i understand mass printing is
bad
but if it's going to the people to
essentially give them the ability to
facilitate
the economic exchange then the debt is
improved by the american people to keep
the machine churning
instead they're doing this mass printing
of money sending money overseas and then
not giving anything to the american
people
for like six months at a certain point
someone's just gonna go
like i'm mad as hell i'm not gonna take
it anymore they're gonna go out their
window and they're gonna scream and rage
or worse i mean you know it could be um
i don't know i mean i guess i'm like i i
i don't
think that's as likely as just sort of
continued
to you know continued banal awfulness
well another thing to really kind of
consider here
is i know a lot of people like to see
this between the left and the right
i think it's even going to be beyond
that i think it's going to be
elements of the left eating themselves
and i think that might even get
pretty violent coming up because the
level of this stain and unpopularity
that this president has
is huge you look at the comments you
look at the responses you look at
yes he was the the most voted for
president in all of american history
ever but it doesn't really reflect on
the excitement there's no one excited
about it the only thing that they have
now
is this trump gravy train that's it's on
its last drips they're still trying to
milk it as much as they can with the 911
commission
about the insurgency and trump but
that's not going to work
and there's going to be a lot of people
pissed off disenfranchised
and i think if there is going to be a
further escalation of conflict of
violence which again we should do
everything in our power to prevent
uh i think it's first going to foment
within the left
versus the left and i think that's going
to lead a spark that's going to be very
interesting and i think that's maybe one
reason why we have these troops still
staying inside of the capital so as far
as the media wants to always keep
dividing and conquering people
they have a debt of accountability they
over promised
and they're not going to deliver and
then people are going to realize that
and they're going to
be very angry well that being said we
should go to super chats huh yeah
if you haven't already smash the like
button because it really really does
help
i think it's important people know that
just interaction commenting
just you know engage with the channel
and uh subscribe
hit the notification bell share the
share the podcast if you really do like
it don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member because we'll have a
bonus segment up
i gotta stop saying that bonus exclusive
segments of the show
sometimes they go along if we get into
like a heated debate we did about
religion it went for an hour it was
really fun and we talked about i think
what was the other one i can't remember
aliens or something
but we do that too so now we're going to
read comments from you
so uh get your super chats in we'll try
and read as many as we can we got justin
bartlett who said
doing my part to contribute to culture
with a weekly podcast called the dine
store cinema
tune in if you're tired of rotten
tomatoes love you all very cool idea i
like that
all right let's see what else we got
matthew hammond says sees the endowments
and the wealthy's investment
nonprofits oh somebody's been reading
myself that's right
yeah so uh sees the endowments i mean
i'm
i'm really tired of the universities uh
and i mean i'm reading this book uh days
of rage i've mentioned this to you
before the show but it's about the 70s
weather underground and
it's the same as antifa the same people
but here's the difference
they they stopped they finally came out
from underground got like three month
probation
and then they went to work as professors
at universities shock
like bill ayers was a professor at uiuc
bernadine doran was a law professor
these people were terrorists
yeah terrorists were terrorists i mean
what i don't mean who knows if they're
still working on bombs but
well no i mean the way i put it is like
if you eat some human does that mean you
were a cannibal or
are you a cannibal a good a fair
question i don't know
if you kill one person are you a
murderer or were you a murderer like
we're paying
you know if they work for a public
university taxpayers are paying for
children to be
educated by terrorists didn't andrew
cuomo pardon
a liberal activist bomber that's now
working for blm that was clinton bill
clinton pardoned that person so clinton
i think also andrew cuomo in a separate
incident barack obama
pardoned oscar lopez rifera who was the
head of the
the i forget exactly what the thing was
was the puerto rican liberation
front they they attacked congress you
want to talk about an insurrection they
literally
shut off congress sure but come on
donald trump pardoned roger stone
i mean come on that guy is like he's
like dr evil i mean
i did not like trump's partners he
pardoned kwame
the new jersey fraud doctor the medical
melligan or something like that black
water mercenaries oh god
these pardons were awful but yup but you
know hey he didn't pardon
puerto rican terrorists yeah okay but
attacked congress
i don't know man that roger stone he's
pretty good he's so dangerous they
needed to raid his home with the fbi
because they knew how big of a threat he
six was the morning and cnn had to be
there they had to be just in case
because we all know roger stone
would come out guns of blazes he'd be
like rambo
and they knew it because of their
groundbreaking investigative journalism
all right let's see where we're at uh
not bob saggett says parlor is a fed
honey pot
also trump won maga uh i don't think
parlor is a honey pot i don't i
don't think so i think i think they're
all tracking you and all spying you know
you're saying trump everything's on a
youtube channel and you think parlor's
the the honeypot like i think i think
the fbi is reading the tim cass comments
yeah well so uh michael malus tweeted
something where he was like to the tsa
agent who
recognized me from cast he's like that
was funny he's like you were nice but i
hate your job or something like that
thanks for being nice even though yeah
yeah exactly well they're not reading
they're databasing
everything and then if they need to go
back they will basically yeah
all right astronaut kitty says is ian
laundering tim's warehouse full of
beanies
the warehouse is not full of beanies it
is full of our pillow
we have the very first prototype if you
want to see it go to instagram.comtimcat
and it's the latest post breaking down
our
our plan for the our pillow product line
groundbreaking
we are going to be when we do launch
where we we're getting the domain set up
we're going to be running ads for this
it will come in a box
it'll be a burlap sack in a box full of
packing peanuts
and we're going to provide very detailed
instructions on how you can build your
own
power pillow so it's a very complicated
process of pouring packing peanuts into
the
burlap
sack and stapling it shut yep and you
think i'm joking
i mean the whole thing is a joke for
sure but i'm going to build this website
i'm going to be selling these things
and it's going to be hilarious and we're
going to spray paint the revolution fist
on it i love it
and we're going to make them
prohibitively expensive and then if
people buy them i'm just going to laugh
like because i guess if you want to get
it it's a luxury item but it's like the
most brutal pillow ever
we're doing it it's happening and we're
going to have tons of them we have one
we have a prototype
john says might not get seen but i live
in portland and i can't confirm that any
of the snow over here can throw the
whole system out of whack
anyone who stops emergency services are
the real bad guys do you guys hear about
that yes
they were they were stopping emergency
services in portland antifa pushed snow
up to the garage door of a police
station so the vehicles couldn't get out
jail evil yes like believe it or not
right through gym yes but no
here's here's the thing seattle is not
equipped for snow it never snows there
and it's extremely steep hills i when i
lived there it
it was a light flurry the whole city
shut down buses were stopping
people were being warned like keep your
cars you know
brakes wheels turned a little bit of
snow and
these hills are ridiculously steep car
starts sliding down and crashing
so for for people who live in chicago
new york or you know in the in the
northeast or people or in the midwest
familiar with snow probably think it's
no big deal like oh whatever
the police can just drive through it not
not in places like seattle
you know and texas right now as well got
that huge snow they're not equipped for
this they're not going to invest heavily
in snow
infrastructure when it snows once every
10 years i guess abilene's out of water
right now
who is abilene the city of abilene in
texas has no
nate hammer says cnn reported the fbi
was having trouble
bringing murder charges on february 2nd
because there was no evidence of blunt
force trauma interesting and that's
crazy
dr doctor says breaking sources close to
nancy pelosi state she has admitted
that she is actually skeletor and
resides in snake mountain with her best
friend chuck schumer aka beastman
and together joe biden aka mechanec will
capture castle grayskull and the source
close to nancy pelosi is a homeless guy
out back yeah
who was about 50 feet away from her when
she was talking he told me everything
i mean that's just that's really big if
it's true i could see it i can see it
being true
bring me he-man with the homeless guy i
don't know any lines from
from from he-man i was too too young for
that
the sinister sibling says i'm just
thinking now we've got my pillow we have
our pillow
how how long before someone say someone
makes mind pillow they actually did that
the left made a joke
where they're mocking mike lindell yeah
so uh
we do have an actual our pillow but it's
just a design
uh if you go to timcast.com and click
shop it brings you to the store and
there's just a regular indoor throw
pillow
and it's got a funny little graphic
where like the mai is crossed out it
says hour
but we actually are gonna be making
making our burlap sec our pillow kits
you have to make it yourself we were
originally gonna send them to you pre
like assembled with you know staples
shut but then i figured it's probably
more insulting to make you do the work
the point is the pillow is brutal we do
nothing for you and it's expensive
but it has the right ideology yes so you
have to buy it
all right sonny james says fbi cia a
joke
been a joke now we are supposed to go to
war with china why
our own government and their state-owned
media does to us what china does to the
chinese only difference
ccp is openly racist and selfish you
can't even defend your own property here
yeah man yep yep yep cole marshall says
tim you once talked about
pots being used on places like reddit in
order to push certain ideas
you don't seem to reference it often why
do you mean you mean bots or sock
puppets
i don't reference it often i mean when i
need to reference it i suppose i do but
i'm not going to randomly bring it up
unless there's a reason to bring it up
but yeah uh sock puppet accounts they're
called sock puppets they're
fake accounts that look like regular
people but they're you know one guy will
have 50 accounts and then
claim it's you know different people
not heisenberg says i gave 500 to
sicknick's gofundme
maybe we can blame that blame the stress
of the situation on his death
i feel furious that i was lied to why
wasn't the gofund clear on his death
and why would you need anonymous sources
for this story
the immediate defense on the left is oh
he had a stroke immediately following
what happened i'm sure that was
unrelated
i mean they said do you have any
evidence of that claim
like we don't i mean or is it the same
anonymous law enforcement sources that
lied to us in the first
instance right like i i think when they
said unrelated it's because they
assessed what caused the stroke and said
it was unrelated
like did they just add that word for no
reason
i suppose so ricky bobby says hey guys
thanks for all you do
tim fyi the okay symbol 100 a symbol
representing white supremacy for example
both correctional officers and
inmates recognize it as such trust me i
would know just some insight
maybe now it is maybe that's that's i
mean it's sort of they memed it into
being one i remember i remember
right like and it was like starting
because i think it was
yeah it was i forget mike ma or
something like that who
who i think he was ultimately
responsible for creating this 4chan meme
to like he was like trump did it yeah so
we're going to deceive
journalists into thinking that the okay
symbol is a white supremacy meme
and journalists were like well that's
really silly of you because now we can
call you all white supremacists
yeah uh so that was they they they don't
i've heard from so many of these people
who think you know yeah but it's funny
because they're dumb and they don't
realize what it means and i'm like dude
the media knows what it means they're
laughing at you
because you've given them a weapon to
convince regular people who don't know
what it means
right why would you do that people don't
understand optics
and information war and propaganda and
the
the journalists were just like oh thank
you so much for doing this
you know your own worst enemy
what's this uh gigi
at this point tmz has more credibility
than nyt
that's the world we live in now that
tabloid papers are more likely to send
reporters to investigate and find proof
than the paper of record isn't that
crazy well this is actually i want to
bring jordan in on this because like you
jordan did
you know actual journalism along with
many other daily caller
daily caller people yeah like going to
riots and the new york times was just
sitting on their ass
doing nothing new york times reporter
was
in one of the riots that i wasn't at but
i heard this story from someone who's
there and the new york times reporter
left because it was unsafe so the new
york times
did not report what happened because
they said it was not safe for the
reporters to be there
but and was it like a leftist right yeah
it was a
it was one of the blm riots did they
publicly write a story saying it was too
dangerous
of course not of course so what they do
is they'll just grab tweets from the
daily caller
while simultaneously insulting them as a
right-wing far-right publication
tucker carlson's the daily caller a
far-right media outlet
had this tweet that's why you know it's
fake blm is peaceful
all right lou cecil says we need to
shift the culture
with more truthful factual documentaries
and movies based on real events
use the power of presentation to red
pill people seeking these genres of
entertainment
that's that's yes absolutely yeah i saw
somebody suggesting we needed better
like we needed some very good
docu-dramas about like the red guards in
china and the cultural revolution
oh yeah absolutely i know poland did
something on kitty and we should be
doing something in english on
the gateway massacre a lot of things you
can do so
so we have justin g who says please stop
saying assault rifles that is not a real
term the media made it up it means
nothing and full auto guns are not
illegal look into it please
all right let's issue some
clarifications the term assault rifle
originated in
nazi germany it was created i believe
hitler coined the term himself
and so assault rifle is a reference to a
selective fire rifle with single burst
and full auto
assault weapon is a term that is
relatively meaningless assault rifle
itself may have been made up a long time
ago
but it does reference something specific
as for full auto guns
not being illegal right the the point
i'm making is that selective fire rifles
are illegal but they're not illegal if
you go through the arduous task
depending on which weapon it is i think
you can get like an m16
you have to fill out what does it look
like the the tax stamp
what is it called the class three form
or something they're
they're prohibitively expensive you
can't make them so just to clarify what
i mean by them not being legal is
there's no new versions of civilian full
auto
you can buy existing ones by going
through a relatively circuitous process
that takes a very long time to do and
then you actually can own these like
sometimes ridiculously powerful crew
served belt fed
machine guns and i went to an event
there's an event called defcon it's a
hacker convention
and they do this thing where they go in
the desert into the mojave and they just
have a shooting range they set up
it's a whole lot of fun and one guy
brought some belt fed
full auto and he was like as long as you
pay for the ammo
you can shoot all you want it's
expensive
because you know at the time i think i
can't remember
exactly uh i think it may have 762 maybe
so at the time it may have been like a
dollar around probably not probably like
50 cents
i don't know i don't know i know the
prices now are getting ridiculously
expensive but
you go to the range today and people are
like i don't want to shoot that much
because bullets are too expensive
like they're hard to come by short
supply
i mean if it's a dollar or a bullet and
you shoot how many bullets a minute
would that thing shoot like
i mean you're spending 100 bucks for a
couple minutes yeah just like doo
yeah today it's it's particularly crazy
there's a lot of ammo that is insanely
expensive
because it's just you can't get it it's
it's it's like it's it's nuts like
i think 30 30 you know not particularly
common to be completely honest but it's
like four bucks
for one bullet you're like you want to
shoot your rifle and you have a 30 30
you know winchester whatever it's like
wow man yeah
but that you can still you can still get
some good prices if you know where to
look i suppose but it's it's getting
it's getting up there man
osiris cleaning llc says you can't have
guns in dc because it's us territory
the amendments were meant to protect the
citizens of several states from the
federal government
that's false yeah that's a federal
constitution the second amendment
applies to the federal government the
right of a free people to bear arms
shall not be infringed
that tell that to dc right like that's
the idea that it's because it's a
federal the constitution
there are areas where like the 14th
amendment was
targeted primarily at the states in the
aftermath of the civil war
that was passed in 1865 the second
amendment was part of the bill of rights
passed with the constitution
like that's that's just wrong sorry yeah
sorry commenter but you are
someone's wrong on the internet no
twisted ninja says does anyone remember
that time that andrew como murdered all
of those old people and covered it up
instead of using the floating hospital
that the president sent
i remember oh and and we now know the
reason he covered it up was because he
was worried
trump would launch a federal
investigation and it would help trump
win
wow so it's trump's fault of course yeah
oh right
it's kind of crazy that uh we just see
it all happening right in front of our
faces
the corruption you know it's just murder
man murder
like he killed these people his press
conference today he was like we reported
all the deaths
or we reported the deaths or he said
something really like twisted and weird
in this press conference it was a
disaster i think he says something akin
to
they're old people they die who cares
yeah so who cares they died yes do they
die in a hospital
nursing home who cares oh my god who
cares
who cares my goodness phillip samnet
says hey tim love the show i'm giving up
youtube for lent so i won't be able to
watch for a while keep telling the truth
whoa whoa whoa there my friend
if you can't watch on on youtube go to
timcast.com
and become a member for exclusive
segments but more importantly
all of this content from my other
youtube channels youtube.com
timcast and timcastnews they're on
itunes spotify
all the podcast platforms and this show
is actually on itunes spotify and all
that as well so
if you want to just listen to the show
we put them up immediately after the
show
just listen on the podcast yeah then you
don't gotta go anywhere
andrew uh says you talked about hr127
please look up hr one oh
yeah what what is that you guys that's
the election reform one
right right national vote by mail stuff
the national republicans never win an
election again is that what it is yeah
it's weird how they want to do that
after winning it's almost like they want
to wield their power to prevent
republicans from ever having power again
that sounds right
you know bottled water says do you need
someone to focus on the ufo uap task
force
there is a lot going on and if you want
someone to help let me know
uh i think we're actually we're planning
on expanding and doing more podcasts
so we have just timcast.com for now but
the goal is to actually make
more site more uh websites and uh we
want to launch
a weird and i don't know why we describe
it as but we want to talk about crazy
conspiracies and
ancient aliens and ufos but from like a
rational
skeptic kind of perspective so you know
i think too much of the enthusiasm
around a lot of these things
is very much desperately wanting to
believe it so
like ghost hunting for example they have
like the electromagnetic frequency
detectors
like who determined that tracks ghosts
you just randomly decided to grab
something
now i want like a rational approach to
what is paranormal phenomenon
do we have experts and scientists who
can tell us why is it that people
experience these things i'll tell you
one thing
they say that ultra low frequencies
could be a reason why people have
uh go like hauntings or ghost sightings
because there's something
that's causing this ultra low frequency
sound to go through you
which can mess with your brain and then
so people in specific areas might see
ghosts when it's really just natural
phenomenon we want
we want to explore that stuff so the
answer is absolutely maybe
uh we have jobs at timcast.com
admittedly
it's not on the front burner right now
so i don't know
who's going to get to it but we're
trying to build as much as we can we
have a lot we have a lot going on that's
making things relatively difficult joe
spinella says original intent of the
second amendment
clearly states i should have the same
long rifle as
my standing army and cannot be infringed
period that doesn't change
government doesn't have the rights and
cannot administrate my property
well there's a lot of people with guns
in uniforms who will stop you
if you try to defend your rights in
certain areas it's absolutely insane
bear arms literally holding it and
walking around
well i mean so to a slight correction
there right like the fifth amendment
says the government cannot take your
property without due process it doesn't
say
it cannot take your property right right
like people often forget
you know how does the government have
the power to do this like people ask me
how the government has the power to
regulate big tech i mean like have you
read the commerce clause it's a big ol
power uh think of the taxing power a big
ol power
it says the government has the right to
tax you and yeah
um so it has a lot of power it has
constraints on that power
and really the thing the way to think
about it is the powers are generally in
the constitution itself and the
restrictions the limitations on the
power are in the bill of rights
and so the second amendment is one key
limitation well there you go
gareth green says pool sunbae and
friends i support the right of any
private property owner to discriminate
on whatever basis they like
no one has the right to step foot on
property they do not own there is no
right to a motel room we must tolerate
that legally
i yeah that's a normative claim that's
wrong right like
i guess no i i shouldn't say wrong just
uh disagree i disagree like vehemently
and i think that uh i i
think it's okay to say that actually no
i don't think you should be able to turn
away
people from your hotel because they're
black i think that's wrong and immoral
and i think
it's perfectly legitimate for government
to put a stop to it and to make that
behavior illegal
i think uh you know i've really thought
about
why we had these laws and when i read
your story about lyndon johnson
it made me kind of realize we if if look
if
you want to create a community somewhere
on an island
or it's getting increasingly difficult
to do because the world is
just a lot of people and jurisdictions
have been formed so i understand that
argument that makes things tough
but if we're even if you go to the
middle of nowhere people argue this yeah
well even if i go to like the mountains
the
government still comes for me and i'm
like because you're still in a country
guarded by all the missiles
that all our taxes pay for and
everything so look i get it it's rough
we were born into a system paying a
subscription fee
but the way i the way i see it is you
get 16 you get
you know 16 years of essentially
partially free living where people
contribute to your existence you get to
use the roads the sidewalk
you get to go to schools and it's paid
for
through public you know contributions
and only then do you have to enter the
workforce and start contributing taxes
to that system
i think the best argument against taxes
is that no one ever chose this
but you didn't choose your parents
either right and they have the right to
discipline you
and i think that you know you really can
go out to the middle of nowhere and kind
of do whatever you want
i think people who argue that probably
have never done that
like i mean within reason i mean
obviously
look we we we talked about the story
where a guy had a
tank with a fifth full auto 50 cal like
50 bmg
and i can't remember where he was but
the police got a call of like
he was shooting into a lake the cops
pulled up the guy stopped shooting waved
and asked if there was a problem they go
this your property and he goes yes sir
and they're like have a nice day and
they left
like you can live in the middle of
nowhere with a tank with 50 bmg full
auto and
so long as you take care of all the
legal process to it
nobody really cares you're doing it i
mean we we still ultimately do live in a
very free country
and i mean i'm trying to fight to
preserve those freedoms
and but and and have them be meaningful
uh
you know in areas like social media but
yeah we shouldn't forget i mean
this is as free as there haven't been
many free countries in the united states
that says
historically speaking as well right when
you travel around the world you really
do realize the the few freedoms that we
have we should
value and protect at all costs and i
mean it's also one other thing to be
scared of is a weak sovereign like that
small
you know people are like well somalia is
great no somalia is bad
it's a mess i've been there i've been
there it's not nice it's not nice
nothing worse you know under a weak
sovereign that is in the middle of a
civil war
i mean your rights are constantly
changing depending on which warlord is
ascendant
remember when uh conan o'brien went to
haiti to prove that trump was wrong
and he went to like this luxury resort
with armed guards and then filmed
himself in the water like it's great
here
it's like dude did wasn't there like an
earthquake that led to a massive like
the u.n
caused a cholera outbreak and then like
covered it up like al jazeera broke that
story
isn't it interesting how whenever some
lib wants to prove that some terrible
place is actually wonderful they
they show you a photo of the ocean which
is
not the country right right right like
there's a bunch of water
you know anna navarro did that she's
like africa is so wonderful view of the
ocean
how about you turned around and looked
at the actual country and showed up well
luke did that
no i was like i did a full like
documentary about somalia that's what i
mean
it showed in the country honesty of it
oh i remember that it was good i was on
the beach
i was on the beachfront too and i met a
canadian there
it was kind of weird but uh you know met
a lot of
crazy interesting people even expats who
moved away from the west
back to somalia i was in i was in
thailand covering you know
the monarchist versus the parliamentary
uprisings
and i was with some vice journalists
this one vice journalist was telling me
what was going on
and explaining how she overheard someone
yell
f the king and then immediately went
like covered her mouth realized it
doesn't matter what the context is
in thailand if you say any string of
words that disparage the royal family
it's called les magistes and it's a
crime you get asked
is that what it is yeah you you go to
jail for that even saying i can't
believe someone said
f the king you're under arrest you said
those words that's crazy
i don't want to live in a place like
that there i remember flying fun to
visit i remember flying out of thailand
and as the planes on the tarmac the
stewardess goes on
the intercom she's like i'm so sorry i
regret tiffany and inform you
our king has died and it was the time
when there was straight
uh no this was six months after the fact
so i'm flying there and she's like i'm
so sorry oh my god we're taking off like
what the hell's going on here
like and she's like you know our supreme
leader has died and i'm like
okay can i go back to sleep now okay
so it was long after but still
they had this morning period which was
extremely long yeah
and and i will say too um i'm probably
pronouncing the name wrong but king
bhumibol was apparently a really awesome
guy
he was trying to bring literacy to the
poor and like really help them out and
people really did love him
even the people who were protesting
against him the ones who would
absolutely disparage the monarchy
in violation of the law would actually
be like but we really do like the king
he's a good dude we just need to change
the system
so like even the people who didn't like
it were very much like he's read
now his son's taken over and that kind
of sentiments kind of changed
when we were working on a documentary
for vice they kept throwing it back to
us because they were like
the way you've described the king's son
is illegal in thailand
and we were like why we're pointing out
other people have criticized them but
you can't do that
so we had to find ways to critically
complement him
like make it sound like it's positive
but it's actually not and it was really
it was really really funny like
i can't remember exactly what we said
but we said he some view him not as a
god but as a demigod
and that was supposed to be i was like
it
what is this doesn't he have like a team
of concubines
right is that i don't know that's the
same person i remember hearing some wild
stuff
uh i don't mean that was older thailand
not recently though
i don't know but i'll tell you this
apparently even me just telling you the
story
means i can't go back to thailand but
it's fine because i was explicitly told
after doing that documentary i was never
able to go back there again
like i was advised by security
organizations like you don't want to go
there
because the dock we did actually got a
bunch of traction and they mocked
like it made the monarchists look really
bad i guess so they were like
yeah they're not gonna want you back and
if you go they might try and so you
shouldn't go to thailand ever again
i'm like all right well i'm grounded he
has a team of concubines it's yeah
that's the current one yes who was it
who had was it gaddafi he had those like
those those lady assassins he had like a
blonde swedish nurse
gaddafi uh gaddafi yes that was his like
main
main chick who was it bottom but was it
mubarak
which one had all of those like female
assassin type guards
uh that was the i think north north
korean leader wasn't it no
no no no it was one of the north african
dictator guys hmm no i don't i don't
remember
well maybe someone in the comments will
yeah but gaddafi
he had a very uh bodacious uh
nurse bodacious what does that mean
you know i don't know i love it had um
endowed
she was well endowed yes there you go
beautiful bazongas
readout production says have you heard
of the west virginia mine wars a
culmination of labor disputes in the
early 1920s
start with a shootout in a town that
opposed coal companies
ended in largest u.s insurrections in
civil war
i didn't know about that i don't know if
it ended in
i mean if it ended in civil war um
it i mean i know there was like
rebellions and it was put down by the
federal government big time
i think el far fivery i'm pronouncing
your name wrong i'm sure
says please try to get maj turay on the
show he's an amazing dude
black guns matter founder for training
for firearms for minority communities
ran for office as a libertarian in
philly super intelligent
and we did have him we have had him yeah
he's a rad dude yes
yeah he's cool i want to come on with a
libertarian sometime and argue with them
do it yeah maybe yeah black guns matter
i mean i i mean on that point i agree
with him i don't really have any
like you know we can we can uh we can
yeah get robbie on we'll do another
debate robbie's cool dude
yeah he's he's a pretty rad guy i just
completely
disagree with him on the regulation
thing but other than that he's pretty
spot on right like he's not the only
person who's wrong about something
yeah yeah he got the covington thing he
was one of the only journalists to
actually get covington
right yeah he nailed that one bobcat
says tim would you hire someone who's
only journalistic experience is serving
in an army recon unit then joining a
private intelligence company for beer
money in college if so where do i send
my resume
that's actually a really good resume
that's good to me would you hire someone
only with extensive reconnaissance sure
yeah i know
well when we start hiring i don't know
you know building this thing out kind of
is kind of a go with the flow thing and
you know to be completely honest we're
just absolutely swamped with launching
our pillow company
you know it's our pillow company and uh
we're gonna run these ads
i'm i'm trying to i'm trying to get see
if ryan long wants to uh help put
together the commercial
and uh hopefully we can just do more
ridiculous things
you know i i just got to say this i was
thinking about i tweeted at elon musk a
while ago i don't know if you guys saw
this i asked him said hey elon musk
why haven't you built an iron man suit
yet and he responded
building starship
[Laughter]
yeah and i responded that is an
acceptable response like
i have nothing to say tonight he's like
all right because that was kind of the
point i was making like yo you're the
super rich guy like where's the cool
batman stuff and he's like i'm building
a starship and i'm like
he's literally doing it all right well
where is anyone else doing anything
interesting to like kind of shake up the
system a little bit not in a crazy
violent way or just
kind of in a funny way to make things
interesting like you know
the pillow thing you know i mean are we
all just kind of demoralized right now
just because
i mean i i think you know i think we're
going to start doing
that it's been weird every you know you
think about how our whole country kind
of
the combination of covid and trump made
our whole country focus on politics in a
way that i think it never had before
yeah um you know team sports got way
less popular its ratings went down
yeah still and so politics kind of
became
replace sports for a lot of people as
their primary con
thing mode of consumption but that's not
it's ultimately not like what produces
innovation
certainly i was thinking where's the
silly commercial where's the silly
billboard where's the
you know just like the interesting out
of like
the just the the weird the like life's
so boring no one does anything
you know it's like everything's so
predictable let's make it let's make you
know what i think we'll sell a bunch of
these pillows
i got to be honest they're not bad no no
joke
like packing peanuts in a burlap sack
surprisingly works
i like it i had a lot of people tell me
like dude i think you think it's bad but
it's probably going to be a really cool
pillow like in terms of temperature
because it's foam and the heat's going
to dissipate very easily through the
holes of the set
the burlap it might be a little rough
laying on because you know it's burlap
but uh
probably comfortable and i tried it you
know you could maybe make it a linen
bag or something like that well it's
gonna be replace the the
packing peanuts i think that would be
replace them with what
with mike lindell's patented fill
i don't know packing peanuts are dirt
cheap true
and all we got to do send people a box
with a with a folded up burlap sack with
a revolution fist on it
in a box of packing peanuts and
instructions and a warning not to use it
as a pillow
and we we we take no responsibility for
anything that happens
to you for keeping this uh i don't think
the ftc is gonna be okay with that sorry
saying what don't use it as a pillow
yeah thought we're gonna have to get a
lawyer and like make sure we go through
it properly
right you might have to rename the
product
or quasi pillow yeah i mean because you
call something a pillow on the title and
then it's
you say but we don't you can't use it as
a pillow that's going to be like
just trade trade deception really
sounds familiar to like other people
what if on the website we just have
something that says like very clearly
this is a joke
it's a gag product you can absolutely
buy and do whatever you want with
just this is why we need you to have
regular very clear about that
like when they're buying it i'll say
this is literally a burlap sack packed
with packing
on that by all peanuts do it we're just
trying to be ridiculous with this
you know yeah okay i mean i think that
would work what if they like spell
pillow
incorrectly like spell it with one
another that wouldn't that wouldn't
solve the issues that wouldn't solve
problems right right
yeah i was i was uh we were
brainstorming ideas for the commercial
and i was like no we still have legal
requirements online even though it's
clearly meant to be ridiculous
it doesn't matter because some people
might not understand that right so
because i was like i had one person
suggest you should say all proceeds will
go to some charity or whatever and i was
like no
we can't do that i'll have to say all
proceeds go to me so i can buy stuff
that i want yeah
right yeah that's literally what we'll
do you don't want to be
deceptive right i mean actually that you
know that's an interesting that's kind
of how
the whole bannon fraud case happened in
southern disney new york right
they went out and publicly said nobody
was going to get paid and then uh
colfage bryan colfage
ended up getting paid well all right
ladies and gentlemen we're gonna we're
gonna jump
over to the ex the exclusive members
only segment coming up at timcast.com so
go there
sign up and in maybe about an hour or so
the next
bonus time will be live and you can
check us out there don't forget to
follow me on now you can follow me on
parlor assuming you can get to load
properly at tim cast
and you can check my other youtube
channels youtube.com timcast
youtube.comcastnews this show is live
monday through friday at 8pm so we'll be
back tomorrow
don't forget to subscribe smash that
like button hit that notification bell
will you want to give any shout outs to
anything um yeah check out the latest
pieces of human events we got a couple
of pieces up from charlie kirk and
david creighton on uh the impeachment
that are pretty solid
um and please please please uh
youtube.com
human events we're trying to build our
own channel right now so
jordan buy our pillow
[Laughter]
our burlap sack thanks for promoting my
company did you have anything
all right sure fine uh luke anyway no
i'm kidding you wanna mention your
social media or
twitter yeah i'm a jordy lancaster on
twitter and um
dailycaller.com jordan lancaster i write
every day so go read me if you're
interested cool
we also forgot to mention that today is
a holiday for people who violated the
constitution i think it's important to
bring that up
um if you like puppies check out my
instagram instagram
hold on hold on yes the conversation
didn't exist for the first few
presidents so uh
they couldn't have violated it most
sorry most of the people that violated i
don't think that's true
the constitution was written when 1789.
and george washington was president when
i'm pretty sure it's starting in 1789
really i don't think you sure i think so
i think will's right on this one
i don't think there was a president i'm
going to say yes federation store my own
personal opinion based on no facts or
evidence at all that's right i think so
so uh what's the verdict on this one no
yeah yeah will's right will's correct
you mean luke was initially saying that
one more time
i love
[Laughter]
so actually uh the effective date was
just before george washington
uh interesting just about uh one month
was when they were like okay we got to
have a constitution
so else correct yes back to more
important matters if you like puppies my
instagram
we are change is where to go the t-shirt
i'm wearing is a picture of george
orwell that says boy did i call it you
could get yours
on thebestpoliticoshirts.com and of
course i'm a youtuber so check me out on
we are change thanks for having me
that's correct i do include luke's at on
youtube in the description of all our
videos that include him because that
seems like a nice thing to do since he
is helping us out he's a wonderful guest
i am sour patch lids on twitter
and minds and i'm real sour patch lids
on instagram and
gab and uh i will hand it over to tim
will be over at timcast.com in the
members only section coming up in about
an hour thanks so much for hanging out
and we will see you all there bye guys
you